Guten Morgen Linos. Guten Morgen Tim. Der Papst meint das Internet nach flatterhaft. Wie geht's dir da so.
Aus dem Alter bin ich raus.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik Nummer zweihundertachtundvierzig vom was haben wir denn? Zwanzigsten März zweitausendachtzehn frisch reingeflattert,
aus dem Mieterebene. Direkt in euer internet verdorbenes Hirn,
Das Internet hat euch verzogen und äh entmenscht.
Ach, ich ich muss sagen so, also das hat mich zu bestimmten Zeiten, da hat mich das Internet auch ein bisschen pflasterhaft gemacht wo.
Ja, aber der in der Zeit macht macht einen alles ein bisschen auf, da kommt jetzt aufs Internet auch nicht mehr so richtig drauf an,
und äh ja, na ja gut, da kann man jetzt lange drüber sinieren. Werden wir äh einem unserer zahlreichen sogenannten Kurz äh Themen widmen
gegen Ende dieser Sendung. Was noch eine Weile ähm in der Ferne zu sein scheint, denn wir haben so das ein oder andere ähm.
Oder andere Kurzmeldung haben wir.
Die ein oder andere Kurzmeldung vorher noch. Na ja und das äh äh die Welt versorgt uns ja auch mit ausreichend Stoff, äh über das es hier zu äh iterieren und sinnieren geht
Ja und außerdem ähm zweihundertachtundvierzig, also.
Da rückt ganz schön was auf uns zu, ne? Wir haben ja eigentlich so eine kleine äh Tradition mal gestartet, dass wir so alle fünfzig Sendungen was Besonderes machen.
Ja, aber ist ja völlig abitär, mach mal das Piepen aus. Also das äh macht macht unsere Hörerschaft verrückt, wenn da die ganze Zeit E-Mails kommen.
Das stimmt. Mich auch übrigens.
Ähm.
Ja. Aber ich glaube die Urlaubskonstellation ähm wird das nicht so richtig ermöglichen, dass wir.
Zu zweihundertfünfzig ähm was Besonderes machen können.
Auch gar nicht, warum man bei einer zweihundertfünfzig was Besonderes machen soll. Das ist eine Zahl, wie jeder andere auch. Ist nicht fünf teilbar. So, das ist jetzt durch zehn teilweise überhaupt nichts besonderes, ja? Und eine besondere Zahl,
Ganz eindeutig die zweihundertsechsundfünfzig.
Bestimmt, weil wir sind ja irgendwie auch noch so.
Darauf warten wir seit der Folge einhundertachtundzwanz.
Im Herzen sind wir achtbittig.
So und das ist was äh das ist was Besonderes, die zweihundertsechsundfünfzig, ja? Die nächste Episode dieser Art wäre erst die fünfhundertzwölf.
Stimmt. Ja. Der ist noch lange hin.
Ja. Ja, das Tim, das wird jedes Mal doppelt der Ab.
Heißt das bei dem Schniller sünden müssen.
Ja ähm ach so, das war übrigens interessant, wir hätten, wir haben letztens mal hier in die Statistiken geschaut und trotzdem wir ab und zu mal Lücken haben, äh veröffentlichen wir im Schnitt alle neun Tage. Das fand ich interessant,
Das war gut. Also wir sind besser als wir dachten.
Ja, nicht nur das, wir äh haben auch ähm was haben wir noch? Wir haben auch ähm.
Zunehmende Hörerzahlen natürlich, was denn noch.
Na ich.
Anzahl der Gesamtstunden, ne?
Die wollte ich jetzt gerade mal produzieren und jetzt ähm versagt hier gerade das User in der.
Live on air versagt.
Nee, nicht pottlauf, wird Pressversagt hier gerade, mein Bü.
Das weißt du, dass das WordPress ist, was.
Na ja, ich kann halt diese Menüs nicht öffnen hier irgendwie zwar alle nicht äh deswegen ist das.
Oder deine Maustasse hat versagt.
Ja. Auf jeden Fall freuen wir uns über äh ungebrochenen Zuspruch auch zu diesem Format. Interessanterweise hat gerade die letzte Sendung doch ähm einiges an Interesse aufgewirbelt.
Das war noch eine interessante Zeit, die vollständige Laufzeit aller Episoden.
Also wenn ihr Logbuch Netzpolitik von vorne bis hinten durchgehend hören wollt.
Also man könnte sagen, dass akkumulierte Gesamtkompromat.
Vierundzwanzig Stunden am Tag. Was gibt's schöneres.
Genau. Ich hätte jetzt so getippt, das werden schon fünf, sechs Tage sein. Was ist eure Schätzung.
Ciao. Drei, zwei, eins.
Vierzehn Komma vier Tage. Das äh hält kein Mensch aus.
Insofern können wir uns zurücklehnen.
Weil wir im Prinzip einfach genug Heu äh draufgeworfen haben, dass äh diese äh Selbstkompromittierende Sammlung an Audion äh Falls äh inzwischen einfach zu groß geworden ist. Hoffentlich.
Vierundvierzig Komma acht Gigabyte ist die vollständige Dateigröße der Medien. Zweiundsiebenunddreißig MB ist die durchschnittliche Dateigröße der Medien.
Ja, das ist jetzt wirklich eine eine Nicht-Zahl, weil da gehören jetzt alle möglichen Formate dazu und so.
Ja, aber die durchschnittliche Laufzeit einer Episode eins, eine Stunde dreiundzwanzig Minuten und sechsunddreißig Sekunden.
Das müssen wir noch auf fünfundvierzig Sekunden kriegen. Vielleicht schaffen wir es mit der heutigen Sammlung.
Jetzt müssen wir mal ausreden, wie lang diese Sendung sein muss.
Aber worauf wir eigentlich hinaus wollten, selbstverständlich ein feiernswertes Ereignis, die zweihundertsechsundfünfzigste Episode von Rockbuch Netzpolitik. Damit ist es einhundertachtundzwanzig Folgen her, dass wir die einhundertachtundzwanzigste Episode gefeiert haben.
Das muss gefeiert werden, weil wir schon.
Die schon vierundsechzig Tage nach der vierundsechzig Mal, nach der vierundsechzigsten und so.
Genau und dann sind's auch nur noch zweihundertsechsundfünfzig Episoden bis zu fünfhundertzwölf, das heißt es ist eigentlich bergfest.
Erst wenn man mal ein K ist, hat man wirklich was geleistet als Podcast.
Vierundzwanzig, ja.
Ich muss unbedingt mal meine meine Sendungsanzahl Sendungsübergreifend äh Podcast übergreifen als zusammenrechnen. Das war schon.
Tausender sein. Ja, wir wollen gerne, wir wollen gerne mal wieder äh was Besonderes machen und wir wollen es in etwa.
In dem Rahmen ablaufen lassen, den wir schon mal gehabt haben zu zweihundertsten Folge, die ja nebenbei auch noch eine Fünf-Jahres-Party war.
Und wo wir sozusagen dem Dizimalsystem gehuldigt haben und jetzt wollen wir dem BNR-System äh huldigen,
Und ähm wir können jetzt noch nicht super konkret werden, weil SU Spic noch leider ein, zwei Details noch nicht ganz so festgezurzt sind, wie wir es gerne hätten. Wollten aber schon mal grob,
andeuten, wann das stattfinden wird und wo, nämlich in Berlin Mitte und wir peilen an Ende Mai, Anfang Juni und ähm,
Guckt euch die Wochenenden an, die da in Frage kommen. Dann könnt ihr ja schon mal im Kopf äh oder auch im Kalender äh euren,
lang geplanten Urlaub umbuchen und dann lassen wir irgendwann auch die Katze aus dem Sack,
wenn wir's definitiv sagen können. Wir hatten ja letzte Mal schon Schwierigkeiten, den Termin recht klar zu kommunizieren, deswegen halten wir es an dieser Stelle nochmal ein bisschen offen
aber sobald der Hammer gefallen ist, werden wir das dann hier auch entsprechend,
Kommunizieren und dann werdet ihr auch schnell die Möglichkeit haben, Tickets zu erwerben und äh an dem ganzen Spaß teilzuhaben.
Ja, man muss dazu sagen, der Tim ist vom letzten Mal gebranntes Kind. Wir hatten da ja äh durchaus etwas äh Schwierigkeiten in der Terminfindung und Tim möchte, dass die
trocken ist und von den äh unterm Vertrag und von den Chefunterhändlern nochmal geprüft wurde,
weil wir ja letzte bei der zweihundert tatsächlich, weiß gar nicht, ob wir das hier erzählt haben, doch haben wir erzählt, ne.
Weiß ich nicht mehr.
Ja, da haben wir für den falschen Tag die Location gebucht, was äh schwierig war, war ja irgendwie in einem, als ich ein Zahlendreher eingeschlichen hatte und so. Insofern, wir belassen das nochmal dann von unseren ähm Beratern prüfen,
Und dann wird hier eine Ankündigung erfolgen für Ende Mai und oder Anfang Juni.
Nicht rund. Zweimal machen wir das nicht. Aber wir würden uns natürlich freuen, wenn wir da möglichst viele von euch dazu kommen. Und ja, wie gesagt, mehr Details. Wenn wir sie haben.
Ansonsten weiß nicht, ach ja, Donnerstag bin ich mal in Hannover. Übrigens bei der heißen Show, da warst du schon mal, ne?
Ja, ich war gerade erst neidisch, dass du die heiße Saison darfst und ich nicht, aber ich war schon mal insofern.
Dass du da auch schon mal warst. Okay. Ach, bist du sonst so schon neidisch auf das, wenn ich mal was mache, was du noch nicht gemacht hast, weil das da eher schon ein Missverhältnis.
Wurde gestern schon wieder gefragt warum äh LNP äh für Linus Neumann Podcast steht,
Die Antwort ist tatsächlich ganz einfach, äh, TPP war schon weg.
Alter.
Äh nee, nee, du darfst.
Genau, ich mache Donnerstag auch noch ein Hörerinnentreffen in Hannover.
Wo kann man sich denn in Hannover treffen? Weiß ich aber noch nicht. Am Bahnhof habe ich den ein.
Das weiß ich auch noch nicht so ganz genau muss noch ich sammel ja immer erst so Interessen und ähm bin dann so sich abzeichnet wie viele Leute kommen, dann so mal eine passende Location.
Also ich würde sagen, die die passende Location ist jeder ein Sixer und dann treffen unter diese.
In der Passerelle eine schöne Straße, die sich da stehen. Unterm Schwanz.
Schöne Statue, die sie da stehen haben. Nee, wie heißt das, dem Kaiser, sein Volk oder dem Führer sein Volk oder sowas.
Unterm Schwanz heißt das.
Unterm Schwanz, ja.
Man trifft sich in Hannover trifft man sich,
Schwanz. Das ist schon ein bisschen Norti, das Hannover. Für die Langweiler trifft man sich dann noch äh,
tut man sich an der Körperuhr, aber äh so unterm Schwanz ist halt ehrlich so angesagt. Genau und da drunter steht ähm dem Landesvatersein,
Volk und es wird immer falsch verstanden als der Hannoversche Kinitiv, das ist natürlich nicht so, aber es gibt schöne Fotos so aus den, aus den Siebzigern, wo dann irgendwie so unter dem,
und dieser Status ist total versoffen, eine verstrahlte Bunks liegen, somit die Flasche in der Hand und dann irgendwie dieses dem Landesvater Sandros Volk, super.
Den Eindruck ehrlich gesagt, dass dieses Bild auch heute noch täglich äh inszeniert wird. Ich bin auch öfter mal in Hannover und gehe immer extra nochmal kurz rausgucken, ob das Volk noch das.
Das Zeug aus seinem Land ist Vater. Wohl nicht.
Geht's dem Volk? Ja. Okay, Donnerstag, Hörerinnen treffen in Hannover.
Auto sieht's aus. So, dann hatten wir Feedback zur letzten Sendung, nicht zu knapp.
Freuen wir uns ja immer und vor allem wenn's um die Details, um die wirklich wichtigen Details geht.
Martin schreibt uns. Hallo Linus. Ich vermute, dass die Lernplattform nicht Elias ausgesprochen wird, sondern
Iljas. Das ist der Name vom Originaltitel von Homers, Epos zum trojanischen Krieg. Das ist doch der Treppenwitz der Geschichte,
auch wenn ich direkt ein Trojaner im Einsatz war. Also äh Rumär habe ich hoffentlich richtig gesagt oder ist das Homer.
Homer Simpson.
Simpsons Oredy Didit. Ähm genau, sehr schön,
dieses, falls ihr Iljas auch nicht kennt, Gegenstand von Iljas ist ja zu dem Zeitbereits seit zehn Jahren während der trojanische Krieg äh zwischen Troja und der griechischen Allianz der Ahajä,
zentrales Thema ist der Zorn, der innerhalb,
Handlungsverlauf, immer weitere Kreise zieht und dabei Heroen und auch Götter in ein unentrinnbares Schicksal zieht. Schreibt die Wikipedia,
Vielleicht äh wenn das so alt ist, vielleicht findet man das auf äh Projekt Gutenberg. Da kommen wir später nochmals.
Aber nicht auf Deutsch. So, dann hatten wir hier den Infrastrukturrückbau.
Haben wir amtlich äh belacht und bekichert, was da alles so vor sich geht. Jetzt ähm,
die Meldung so ein bisschen die Runde gemacht und alle Beteiligten schienen sich da nochmal groß äußern zu müssen, insbesondere die Telekom
die halt meinen, ah, nee, hier alles äh ein Spaß so. Wir äh wir waren nie im Krieg mit Orasien,
äh mit EWE und also Hintergrund der Geschichte letztes Mal war ja Telekom kündigt den,
Kunden ihr schnelles Internet und sagt jetzt dafür kriegt er aber langsames Internet, weil dann blöde Ausrede auf Nachfrage, na ja, wir werden ja von der Bundesnetzagentur dazu gezwungen. Da ist wohl jemand sehr inkompetentes am Werk
gewesen und der Hintergrund stellt sich jetzt so dar, dass diese ganze Geschichte eine temporäre Geschichte ist, wo halt
EWE diese Anschlusspunkten übernimmt, also da wo bisher die Telekom
die Versorgungshoheit hatte, hat sie jetzt EWE, wir wissen ja alle, dass dieses Viktoring, also diese hundert Megabit äh Kupfer aus ähm Weidung.
Äh zur Konsequenz hat
dass nur ein einziger Betreiber diesen Schrank, also alle Anschlüsse dieses Schranks betreiben kann für die Kunden, weil quasi über alle Kabel hinweg hier ein Frequenzmanagement gepflegt werden muss, weil es sonst eben überhaupt nicht funktioniert
und damit können dann eben nicht mehrere Betreiber so auf den letzten Metern
versorgen wie sie möchten und wie die Kunden das gekauft haben, sondern es muss dann eben so Untervermietung einsetzen. Dann hieß es ja, die hätten sich nicht geeinigt.
Das wird jetzt wohl anders dargestellt. Es ist äh alles super wäre. Man man würde sich da machen, nur diese Kündigung wäre halt jetzt sozusagen vorläufig möglich. Allerdings könne man halt danach,
nicht diese im Verträge anbieten, war ja sowas wie Entertaine, et cetera, darauf basiert, dass eben diese Last-Mal-Versorgung vor der Telekom gemacht wird, um eben diese hohen Taktungen für Internetfernsehen et cetera garantieren zu können,
Und das ist natürlich ein interessanter Nebeneffekt, ähm wo man mir da mal so schön sieht, ne, wie das äh,
Nicht nicht konsequent überall verfügbare Netzneutralität äh zu solchen Verzerrungen führt und mal zu Vorteilen, mal zu Nachteilen von Unternehmen. Äh die Zielgruppe kann halt,
dieses Produkt nicht überall anbieten, weil das quasi ein Produkt ist, was nur möglich ist, wenn man eben.
Äh das habe ich auch nie verstanden dieses T-Entertain.
Das Fernsehen hal.
Ja, habe ich auch nie verstanden.
Fernsehen halt.
Aber ansonsten äh schrieb Sven noch dazu. Es handelt sich bei EWE um ein Akronym und wird als Buchstaben gesprochen, wie zum Beispiel TCP. Also heißt sie wohl E-Double You.
Verstehe ich so.
Na oder TCP, also oder you?
Was ist da, was machen die? Auch Fernsehen oder.
Eine IWE, wenn du das halt auf Englisch als nicht einzelne Buchstaben aber aussprichst, dann würde halt die EU bei rauskommen.
Mhm. Mhm. Okay, also.
Eve. Okay, also kein T-Entertain. Ich denke, das ist verschmerzlich. Hoffentlich für die meisten Kunden in äh welches Land weiß nochmal Niedersachsen, ne.
Dann haben wir noch äh eine kurze Anmerkung,
von äh du hast die Namen hier wieder aus dem Ding raus entf.
Was? Ich habe überhaupt nicht. Was für Namen.
Ähm.
Nein, ich habe die überhaupt erst eingefügt, du.
Ne? Also.
Doch. Also. Da unten steht's bei den Dings.
Naja, nee, nee, ne.
Der andere ist auch von dir. Also hier. Ich habe, ich habe keine Namen mehr.
Also hier auf jeden Fall sorry, dass ich da, der Tim hat deinen Namen gelöscht. Huhu, Anmerkung, die Frau Bea ist für digitales zuständig, also alles bis auf Netzausbau. Der ist nicht mit ins Kanzleramt gezogen, sondern bleibt im Verkehrsministeriu.
Untergehe hat das gesagt. Stand da aber nicht.
Genau, weil du es gelöscht hast.
Nein. Nein, ich habe das nicht. Habe ich nicht gemacht. Nein. Greift ein Hörer. Sinus ist gemein zu mir.
Dann wurde gesagt, äh warum kämpfen Verlage? Das fragt Julius. Warum kämpfen Verlage gegen den öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk? Aber das private Fernsehen nicht. Ähm,
Das ist eine lange, interessante Geschichte, die wo ich nur eine kurze Vermutung als Antwort geben kann
primär, weil die, weil das Privatfernsehen froh sein kann, dass es das Privatfernsehen überhaupt gibt, denn ähm dass wir überhaupt Privatfernsehen haben
ist erst nachher gekommen. Es gab äh lange Zeit nur die öffentlich-rechtlichen äh Programme und es gibt einen wunderschönen äh Spiegelatikel vo,
vom ersten Oktober neunzehnhundertneunundsiebzig, wo Bundeskanzler ähm Helmut Schmidt,
sich dazu äußert und sagt Privatfernsehen ist gefährlicher als Kernenergie.
Bundeskanzler Helmut Schmidt erwägt den Streit um private Fernsehprogramme zum Wahlkampfthema neunzehnhunder
achtzig zu machen. Die geplante Verkabelung von Städten ist vorerst gestoppt, um die Bürger vor den schädlichen Einflüssen einer Reizüberflutung zu schützen, wollen die Sozialdemokraten notfalls das Grundgesetz ändern.
So wurde so wurde diese Debatte geführt und da hätte uns natürlich, würde man jetzt im Nachhinein sagen, eine Menge erspart bleiben können, äh wenn Helmut Schmidt sich damals durchgesetzt hätte. Insofern glaube ich, dass die ähm,
dass äh deswegen da die rechtlichen Rahmenbedingungen ganz andere sind, dass eben,
quasi einerseits die Verlage aufgrund des Rundfunksauftrages Grund haben oder juristischen Anlass haben und juristischen Hebel haben, sich dagegen zu wehren, dass das öffentlich-rechtliche Fernsehen in ähm,
Zeitungsverlagswesens Marktbereichen tätig ist. TV private TV-Sender aber nicht sagen können, ne ähm.
Das äh wollen wir nicht, weil die rechtliche Situation hier eben ist, die sind nachher gekommen. Das wäre jetzt meine sehr leidenhafte,
Pretation.
Auch in dem Artikel sagt Witz äh Schmidt zitiert, mit würden die Bürger mit privaten Kabel oder Satellitenprogramm überflutet, dann äh könnte dies die Strukturen der demokratischen Gesellschaft verändern.
Hat es, zweifelsohne. Ähm dann noch ein Kommentar von Steffen Uhlig zu dem Thema Netzausbau. Wir bleiben also beim Netzausbau. Euren
Optimismus in Ehren, aber was läuft, lässt euch glauben, dass eine staatliche Behörde den Aufbau einer bundesweiten Glasfaserinfrastruktur auch nur halbwegs transparent und effizient hinbekommt. Lala, la la, gerade im CCC-Umfeld wundert mich das Vertrauen in einen der Staat, muss es richt
schon sehr. Ähm interessanterweise, dass es unbedingt der Staat machen soll, ist gar nicht unser Kernargument. Das Kernargument ist, dass der Netzausbau von jemand
anderem erfolgen soll, als von denen, die das Netz nachher benutzen. Und dass dieser jemand andere,
gezwungen ist, ähm allen anderen gleichen Zugang dazu zu bieten, sodass man unter den ISPs gleichen, also Wettbewerb auf Augenhöhe hat
Weil die Infrastruktur, die genutzt wird, von jemand anderen Betrieben und zu gleichen Konditionen an alle ISPs gegeben werden muss.
Genau, das ist der Punkt, natürlich ist es hier oder macht es den Eindruck relativ klar, dass hier der Staat,
Diese Regeln dafür aufstellen muss. Das heißt nicht unbedingt, dass er durchgehend Betreiber dessen ist, aber er muss zumindest ähm sicherstellen, dass
so ein System läuft, ja? Also äh ich denke jetzt auch nicht, dass wir jetzt irgendwie Beamte sehen, die Netzwerkrauter äh konfigurieren, aber
dass es hier auch gar nicht äh gar nicht der Punkt, ja, sondern da muss man sich halt ein entsprechendes Konstrukt einfallen lassen,
gibt's ja auch in vielen anderen Ländern, kann man sich angucken, kann man hinfahren, kann man drüber reden, kann schauen, wie kompatibel das ist. Das Ziel ist zumindest klar und daran kann man dann eben die erforderlichen Strukturen sicherlich auch
ausrichten. Wenn man denn dann überhaupt den Wunsch hat, das überhaupt zu machen und nicht nach wie vor an diesem Gedanken festhält, na ja, wieso, uns gehört ja die Telekom und es ist ja auch ganz gut für Startsäcke und.
Daran anschließend kommentiert Tobi,
mit in einem etwas längeren Post. Ich schlage folgende Begriffe vor, jetzt sind das alles Begriffe, die es vorher auch schon gab, deren Verwendung er uns naheliegt. Äh erstens natürliches Monopol, ein Netz wie unser Kupfer und Glasnetz
ist ein natürliches Monopol.
Ich denke, das kann keiner bestreiten. Die Eintrittsbarrieren in den Markt sind so hoch, dass kein sinnvoller Wettbewerb entstehen kann. Die herrschende,
Marktteilnehmerin kann das Angebot künstlich verknappen, um dann möglichst hohe Preise zu erzielen. Zudem kann die Marktteilnehmerin
Es anderen Anbietern durch verschiedene Techniken schwer machen auf dem Markt zu bestehen. Ein solcher Markt wird automatisch immer in einem Monopol enden. Das ist die Situation, die wir in Deutschland quasi
zu beklagen haben. Er nennt außerdem noch die Begriffe Marktversagen, öffentliches Gut und,
Ähnliches, die also noch mehr äh über diesen Zusammenhang nachdenken lassen und geprangert an, dass ich solche Begriffe nicht äh verwendet habe. Ich habe mich bemüht,
ist eher zu umschreiben und nachvollziehbar zu erklären. Ähm wenn ihr da nochmal äh die Fach,
Fachbegriffe und Fachliteratur aus äh wahrscheinlich volkswirtschaftlicher Perspektive nachlesen wollt, findet ihr den.
Äh Kommentar bei uns verlinkt und das ist da sehr gut,
erklärt. Also öffentliches Gut, ein solches Netz muss daher ein öffentliches Gut sein, weil und so weiter. Sehr schön. Da habe ich einen Marktversagen verhindert werden kann.
Schöner wichtiger Kommentar.
So und er sagt auch, wenn wir diese Begriffe verwenden, dann sagt äh sagt er nie wieder Cyber.
Wir aber. Cybers, Cybers, Cybers, Cybers, Hybers, Higra.
Alles wieder eingerissen.
Jetzt habe ich dir glaube ich einen Kommentar weggenommen, weil den nächsten muss auch ich machen, ne?
Ähm macht ja nichts. Ich kann ja kluge Kommentare dazu geben.
Oder du machst erstmal den zur Upload-Filtern. Okay, ähm Kommentar von Deos Figendi, hm der sagt äh.
Nee, sorry äh von Herr Bert. Deos Figurni hat ja nur drauf geantwortet. Was Linos zum Aufmachen von Verschlüsselung an zentraler Stelle,
um zu gucken, ob da was Sicherheitsbedenkliches geschieht, erzählt hat, klingt wie das, was ihr am Anwaltspostfach kritisiert habt. Ähm Zusammenhang hier.
Ähm es ging dabei darum um diese Organisations und Unternehmens,
Netzwerke, insbesondere wo ich auch den IVB geschildert habe, wo ich gesagt habe, üblicherweise baut man in solchen Netzen das so, äh dass man sagt,
Wir machen einen zentralen Webproxi, alles was raus ins Webfel geht durch diesen Proxi,
und zur Unterbindung verschlüsselter Verbindungen,
macht dieser Webproxi ein männende Mittelangriff, das ist genau richtig, äh hat Herr Bert genau richtig dort geschrieben, beschrieben, was der Proxi nämlich macht, ist, er stellt zur einen Seite die verschlüsselte Verbindung her, ähm,
Er macht also den die stellt den äh SSL-Kontext her mit der äh mit der Seite, die ihr aufruft bietet euch aber innerhalb dieses Netzes im Prinzip mit seinem eigenen Zertifikat die Verbindung nochmal an,
Und wenn ihr in einem solchen Unternehmensnetz seid, dann seht ihr das in der Regel daran, dass ihr an dem, wenn ihr dann oben auf die Zertifikatprüfung geht,
dann da steht, ja was weiß ich, ihr seid auf WWW Postbank DE,
Äh und die vertrauenswürdigkeit der Verbindung wird garantiert von einem Zertifikat, das eurem Arbeitgeber äh gehört. Und das ist dann eben bei jeder Seite, die er besucht der Fall.
Und ja das ist genau richtig, das ist ein männende Mittelangriff ähm auf den kompletten Datenverkehr des Unternehmens vom Unternehmen selber,
Und ähm der einzige Punkt, den ich dazu sagen möchte, ist, weil da sagt Andreos Fegende, er kann äh er hat auch äh geschluckt und meint, dass das ja wohl nicht sein kann, dass ich das äh gut finde,
Nee, habe ich auch nicht gesagt, dass ich das gut finde. Ich hab's nur geschildert,
Und ähm damit dieser männende Mittelangriff funktioniert, muss dieses Zertifikat, was der männende Mittelproxi verwendet, auch in euren Endgeräten als vertrauenswürdig,
ein äh gespeichert worden sein, dass ihr also sagt, okay, hier gibt es eine CA, der wir vertrauen.
Und das ist in der Regel dann der Fall, weil der, weil dieser, weil dieses und weil dieser Rechner, den ihr bedient, auch nochmal in einem
Active Directory hängt äh und ihr da eh nicht und Zentral verwaltet wird und ihr da eh nicht die Kontrolle drüber habt. Das heißt mit eurem eigenen Rechn,
solltet ihr in der Lage sein, euren Eigenrechner in diesem Netzwerk anzuschließen, würdet ihr äh am laufenden Band Zertifikatswarnungen bekommen,
Und ähm ja ist leider Gottesgängige Praxis,
In größeren Unternehmen und in sogenannten sicheren Netzwerken und es ist auf jeden Fall eine ähm Verletzung der Privatsphäre,
der Angestellten die rechtliche Grundlage dafür ist aber dass man in der Regel dann
beim Eintritt in diese in dieses Anstellungsverhältnis eine Datenschutzerklärung zu diesem Mängelmittelangriff unterzeichnet ähm und unter
Umständen natürlich dieser Proxi auch so konfiguriert werden kann, dass er bestimmte Verbindungen nicht männende Mittel zum Beispiel, was weiß ich, GMA machen wir nicht,
aber in der Regel sowieso auch noch unterschrieben habt, dass ihr keine privaten äh Internetnutzungen während der Arbeitszeit vom Arbeitsrechner macht. Ähm,
Äh sind solche Regelungen eher im Rahmen der Großzügigkeit,
Aber ja, das ist wird getan und es ist leider so eine ähm also ist auf jeden Fall eine sehr starke Datenschutz und ein sehr großer Datenschutz und Vertrauensbruch.
Ähm gleichzeitig wenn dir, wenn man tatsächlich davon ausgeht, dass man,
Ziel von fortgeschrittenen Trojaner Angriffen sein könnte, ist das hier eine,
Wahrscheinlich als notwendig zu bezeichnende Maßnahme ähm verschlüsselte Verbindungen nach besten,
Wissen und Gewissen,
zu unterbinden und gleichzeitig das äh dafür einen rechtlichen Rahmen im Sinne einer Datenschutzvereinbarung zu finden. Gut finde ich das auch nicht. Hat übrigens auch noch Nachteile, weil die teilweise, ich bin ja,
relativ oft in Unternehmen unterwegs, äh weil die meistens äh auch noch Scheiße konfuriert sind, diese Proxis, sodass sie einem ähm tatsächliche männende Mittelangriffe
oder kaputte Zertifikate nicht anzeigen.
Ähm weil ich da mal äh zu einem zu Demonstrationszwecken in einem Unternehmen eine Seite mit einem kaputten SSL-Zertifikat besuchen wollte und gesagt habe, jetzt guck mal, geh mal kurz auf die Seite, dann siehst du mal die Zertifikatswarnung
dann kam keine, weil der Proxi sagte, ah ja, hier alles gut so, ich signiere die die Verbindung,
und hat's dann einfach durchgegeben. Das heißt, da,
durch dieses Sicherheitsfeature hat mir sich da wieder das nächste Sicherheitsproblem äh geholt, dass nämlich theoretisch männende Mittelangriffe in dieser Konfiguration, die ich da gesehen habe, nicht erkannt.
Wurden oder fehlerhafte Zertifikate nicht gewarnt wurden. Es geht hin und her und hier ist auf jeden Fall ein Abwägen.
Notwendig und äh man muss eben sagen, der Skope hier ist dann eben ein größeres Netzwerk, ein, äh, wo man eine Organisation schützen möchte und da wird so etwas getan aus,
Persönlichen Gründen heiße ich das nicht gut, aber ich bin zumindest nicht in der Lage, eine sehr viel bessere Alternative zu vorzuschlagen, wenn eben das Ziel ist, hier ein Hochsicherheitsnetz zu bauen.
Dann gab's noch Feedback zu unserer Diskussion über Upload, äh Filter, da hatten wir dieses diese Meldung gebracht, dass Pingstings quasi so äh durch diese Content ID automatische Erkennung auf YouTube.
Ihren eigenen Content äh weggehauen bekommen hat, weil der wiederum von RTL in einem Beitrag äh wiedergegeben wurde und ähm das sozusagen hintenrum ähm,
ihn auf die Füße gefallen ist,
Dazu gab's ein paar längere Anmerkungen von Deos äh Figendy für verschiedene Aspekte. Letztlich meint er, gleichzeitig,
möchte ich noch einwerfen, dass es natürlich verständlich ist, dass man gerade als Aktivist auch präsent sein will, also auf diesen Plattformen und muss auf den großen Plattformen ohne YouTube und Facebook und Twitter wird's eben schwierig heutzutage, aber ich finde,
man sollte sich nie auf diese verlassen, man sollte sie benutzen, um die eigenen Inhalte zu bewerben, die man auf eigener Infrastruktur vorhält. Also das Video auf YouTube hochladen, total richtig ist von YouTube auf der eigenen Webseite einbinden,
total falsch. Ja.
Pinkstings wären halt mit ihrem Video niemals so viral gegangen, ne? Also ob sie's der der Aspekt das ist auf ihrer eigenen Seite haben hätte jetzt der äh der war nicht für diese Viralität verantwortlich. Leider, ja, also ich.
Äh du kriegst eben dein ein Video im Zweifelsfall nicht von eigener Infrastruktur an den Punkt, dass es viral ist.
Wenn du aus dem wenn du von null anfangen musst,
Insofern das Problem hätten sie trotzdem gehabt, ob's auf ihrer Seite eingebunden ist oder nicht, aber der trotzdem ist der das der Punkt, den Deos Figende hier bringt natürlich richtig
Man sollte sich nicht in die
Abhängigkeit begeben und diese Anbieter zur Primärquelle machen. Das ist absolut wichtiger Punkt. Ich weiß nur nicht, ob er in dieser Situation so viel geholfen hätte.
Ja, also,
Da sind verschiedene Ebenen jetzt mit drin, so was was bringt einen dazu, Plattform überhaupt zu benutzen, gerade bei Videos und bei Videos mit großer Verbreitung und so weiter. Also,
viel Videomaterial oder extrem populäres Videomaterial auf eigenen Servern zu husten. Ist gar nicht so einfach
weil Treffweg et cetera kann man schon irgendwie machen, geht schon, aber kostet halt dann auch Geld. Und da sind natürlich diese kostet eigentlich überhaupt nichts. Äh, Option mit YouTube, mit äh tausend Prozies, weltweit, Around World, mit immer schnellem Zugriff garantiert und garantiert
nicht geblockt im Sinne von generell Aktuf zu YouTube. Na ja okay, haben wir auch schon Ausnahmen gehab
Egal. Auf jeden Fall das ist natürlich sehr attraktiv. Man liefert sich natürlich dann eben diesen Bedingungen dieser Plattform aus und äh diese Bedingungen sind auch nicht ganz unerheblich. Also es ist zum Beispiel kein,
kein Zufall, dass es Meterebene Content nicht auf YouTube gibt,
und auch nicht auf irgendeiner anderen Plattform, sondern die einzige Plattform, wo es angeboten wird, ist halt die Mieterebene selber.
Dann noch eine kleine Hinweis in eigener Sache. Wir unterhalten ja eine Facebook-Seite ähm auf diese Facebook-Seite habe ich bisher immer automatisch über so ein,
schieben lassen, die wir ähm,
In Lokbuch Netzpolitik verwenden für die Sendungsvorbereitung, also Sendungsvorbereitungen für Logbuch läuft, so ich.
Oder wir lesen Nachrichten und immer wenn uns da was gefällt, dann klicken wir auf so ein Book Market und dann fällt das in die Sendungssammlung und wird dann eben auch,
zeitnah wurde dann eben auch zeitnah in dieser Facebook-Seite veröffentlicht. Äh das habe ich jetzt mal abgeschaltet
Der Grund dafür ist, dass sich da auch immer wieder mal Diskussionen unter diesen Artikeln, die wir da verlinkt haben, ergeben haben und ähm ich,
mich nicht in der Lage sehe, diese dieses Facebook Interface zu bedienen, um in diesen Diskussionen irgendwie zu antworten und da waren dann auch mal
natürlich die ein oder andere fragwürdige Quelle, die wir verlinken mit dabei, insbesondere jetzt zu diesen AMD, CPU-Ding, wo dann diskutiert wurde. Äh warum postet ihr diese unseriöse Quelle? Ja,
stimmt und äh hätte mein Ziel war nicht dazu Verbreitungen zu schaffen, sondern mein Ziel war die für mich als Bookmarkt da zu haben,
Und äh da man das nicht unterscheiden kann, haben wir es jetzt einfach mal ausgeschaltet, das heißt auf der Facebookseite von Logbuch Netzpolitik gibt's jetzt nur noch erscheinende Folgen von Lokbuch-Netzpolitik und das ist doch wunderschön, dann könnt ihr der nämlich alle folgen,
und wenn dann da nach, wenn dann da äh Episoden veröffentlicht werden, dann könnt ihr die Facebooken,
für eure Freunde und dann haben wir mehr Facebook Follower und dann.
Dann sind wir wieder wer. Also äh pusht pusht unsere Facebook-Seite, aber bitte bitte schickt uns keine Facebook-Nachrichten. Das war das Andere, was ich bei der Gelegenheit gesehen habe. Da sind halt Facebook-Nachrichten hingeschickt worden und ähm das äh,
kommen halt nicht an. Also wir müssen da leider sagen, wir pflegen diese Seite nicht, das ist ein das ist die kriegt genau den Aufwand, den.
Dem wir glauben, der Facebook gebührt.
War ja deine Idee.
Ihr seht, ich habe selbst das zu tun, habe ich hier habe ich hier großen Druck.
Was heißt Druck? Du hast das einfach gemacht
ich hab mich da jetzt nicht groß gegen gewehrt aber ich verspür da halt auch keine Euphorie, weil ich kenn das ganze Elend ja schon, das ist halt einfach ein extrem schwer zu kontrollierendes Outlet und darüber hinaus
ähm finde ich halt einfach eine eine Plattform wo potentielle Interesse wo ich mir im Prinzip mit Geld auch noch die
Interessenten dazu kaufen müsse, absolut nicht okay.
Nein, absolut nicht, deswegen sage ich ja, bitte rief Facebook unsere äh Posts, damit.
Ist das überhaupt singen? Richtig Facebook? Was weiß ich.
Weiß ich nicht, haben die kein Redfeed? Like, ich.
Muss ja immer alles liken, muss mal alles geil finden.
Kann man aber nicht weiterempfehlen? Nee, wahrscheinlich nicht, ne? Die wollen ja damit Geld verdienen.
Also Dorothee Bär, meiner Facebook-Werte für alte Leute, aber ehrlich gesagt, kann man alten Leuten nicht empfehlen.
Wir bleiben wir bleiben schön bei den bei den Journalisten, Politikern und Psychopathen. Da fühlen wir uns wohl.
Ich weiß, dass wir es vielleicht für manche Leute, die das äh regelmäßig benutzen, mega Ignorant rüberkommen. Was daran liegt, dass wir das wahrscheinlich in dem Moment auch sind,
Äh
Deswegen möchte ich also ich möchte da vertreten.
Ich kann, ich kann, ich kann einfach auch kein System benutzen, mit dem ich nicht selber warm geworden bin. Ich benutze viele Sachen auch nicht. Ich bin auf,
allem irgendwie so ein bisschen da. Ja, ihr werdet kaum,
Netze oder zumindest halbwegs populäre Netze finden, wo es nicht mindestens irgendwie ein Tim Pridler äh Account gibt, weil ich schon mal vorbeigekommen bin, mal geschaut habe und so. Aber,
wenn ich nicht warm werde damit, dann dann ja habe ich auch kein Problem damit so als Netzleiche da rumzulegen auf Abruf. Ähm,
Mit Facebook ging's mir schon immer so. Immer, immer, immer, immer, immer, immer, immer, immer, immer, immer, immer, immer, immer, immer, immer und wir werden ja auch gleich nochmal über Facebook,
länger und ausführlicher reden und das trägt nicht unbedingt dazu bei, diese Meinung zu ändern, ja? Ich weiß, die Kalender, die Partyeinladung, die anderen des sozialen Netzwerk,
Peopleshare geschenkt, verstehe ich ja ich weiß es, ist auch schade, dass.
Aber dann wundert, dann wundert ihr euch, dann wundert ihr euch, liebe Kinder, dass ihr ganz flatterhaft seid, wenn ihr da den ganzen Tag auf Facebook rumhäng.
Na gut, das schauen wir gleich nochmal. Vorher noch ein äh letztes Feedback.
Da haben wir ja ein wenig äh realisiert und ähm.
Philosophiert und resümiert, äh.
Wenn du hier schon irgendwie einen auf überh.
Intellektuell machst? Machst du noch mit den richtigen Worten,
Genau, wir resieren dann später vielleicht nochmal. Also wir haben uns über online äh Modelle, Kontext von Adblockern und so weiter, also Online-Verdienstmodelle, Gedanken gemacht und
ne, auch so diese generelle Problematik einfach nochmal hingestellt. Dazu Kommentar von Nebukat Nitza,
bezüglich Paywall und freier Zugang finde ich das Modell des Onlinemagazins Republik Punkt CH,
noch interessant. Man muss dafür bezahlen, dass man über die aktuellen Infoartikel informiert wird und sie alle lesen kann,
Wenn man jedoch den direkten Link auf einen Artikel kennt, kann man ihn ohne Probleme lesen und bekommt lediglich eine Männerung angezeigt, dass einem der Artikel von der bezahlenden, von den bezahlenden Lesern geschenkt wurde.
Habe ich jetzt noch nicht ausprobiert. Ist aber in der Tat ein interessantes Modell,
Weil wenn man sozusagen richtig Interesse hat an einem Portal als Nachrichtenquelle so,
Was weiß ich so wie Spiel Online aufrufen, irgendwas passiert und nee, nur Bundesregierung äh kann weiterschlafen. So, dann.
Nutzt man ja im Prinzip das so als Primärquelle.
Mal auf einen Link irgendwo hingeschickt zu werden, wie bei der Bild, die haben dann gleich hier irgendwie erzählt, so oh ja, hier at Blogger.
Das alles deinstalliert.
Bladen. Ja, also ich bin immer ganz dankbar, der Bild so, weil ich dann vielleicht in dem Moment gar nicht gemerkt habe, dass ich da einen Bildlink anklicke, weil Bittly Plan, ne? Äh man weiß ja schon gar nicht mehr, worauf man klickt im Internet,
Ähm ja, da jetzt mir einfach mal hier so äh hingestellt, ich.
Mich da bei dem hab da noch kein Link glaube ich bekommen, aber das sagen wir mal, das ist aber durchaus etwas, was.
Was das eigentliche Problem löst, ne? Weil man will ja irgendwie Suchmaschinen zugänglich sein. Man will ja sozusagen verlinkbar, twitterbar sein, et cetera oder Facebook bla verlinkbar sein.
Das ist halt der Hintergrund, ne, dass man also die,
dass es eigentlich eine Werbemaßnahme ist zu sagen äh ja wenn wenn ihr das wenn ihr über Twitter hierher kommt. Wir wollen also den den viralen Teil des Netzes, den nehmen wir gerne mit, aber wenn du wenn du wirklich ähm,
Regelmäßiger Nutzer unseres Angebotes äh sein möchtest, dann verlangen wir ein bisschen Geld von dir. Ich weiß nicht, also ich find's Nutzern gegenüber ganz fair,
Weil es eben den Casual Nutzer und die Verlinkbarkeit und so weiter äh äh sicherstellt. Ähm ich frage mich aber.
Allerdings ja, das weiß ich auch nicht, aber zweihundertvierzig Franken im Jahr, das ist schon harbig. Na ja, Audi. Haben's ja auch. Wir haben's ja auch.
Abends auch. Eine Dose Bier und ein Zeitungsab.
Berlin Tarif.
Okay, also.
Na ja, also ich kenne das Projekt nicht kennt's, kennst du es, äh unabhängiger Journalismus, Werbefrei, also.
Werbefrei sogar.
Na ja gut, das will man ja dann. Wo erwarten. Also ob dann die Links, die nicht übern äh also ob das auch für die geteilten Links gilt, weiß ich nicht. Ja.
Gönner Mitgliedschaft auch noch machen Tim.
Nein, also schöne,
Immerhin mal ein Modell. Wir schauen jetzt mal an, ob sie damit klarkommen. Ähm ähnlich glaube ich, ehrlich gesagt war das doch hier das äh ich weiß gar nicht, ob's die noch gibt. Krautreporter,
glaube ich ziemlich genauso gemacht. Also die Idee gab's nicht nur.
Mit dem Modell, mit.
Glaube ja und ich glaube auch, dass das bei äh bei New York Times oder Washington Post auch so ist,
du teilweise ist es halt so, dass du dann irgendwie siehst du kannst nicht weiterlesen. Und wenn du aber mit einem Google-Reführer kommst, kriegst du einen ganzen Artikel. Das heißt, du musst die Headline googeln und dann entweder draufklicken, um dann den ganzen Artikel zu sehen und irgendwie solche solche Tricks gibt es,
Mal schauen, ob die sich als ökonomisch gangbar am Ende äh entpuppen. Das ist glaube ich die Frage, die sich da stellt,
oder angenehm sind sie allemal.
Gut, dann äh kommen wir mal zu unserem ersten richtigen Thema.
Ja
Einen Thema, das wir in Logbuch, Netzpolitik zweihundertdrei mit dem äh Unglück im Glück, im Unglück eigentlich schon sehr ausführlich behandelt haben, nämlich das Unternehmen,
Cambridge Analytica. Ähm.
Dieses Unternehmen hat auf Facebook gewirkt, hat dort eine ähm eine App angeboten.
Ähm und äh dadurch eben Wissen über die Nutzer und deren Freunde,
gesammelt und daraus Persönlichkeitsprofile gemacht und diese Persönlichkeitsprofile dann genutzt, um,
zielgerichtete Werbung an diese Personen auszuspielen. Ähm das wurde.
Eben letztes Jahr schon einmal skandalisiert,
wo es dann diesen doch sehr sportlichen Artikel gab mit dem Titel ich habe die Bombe nicht gebaut, ich habe nur gezeigt, dass es sie gibt, wo jemand also meinte, er wäre jetzt hier der,
der Erfinder der Idee,
Die Daten, die bei Facebook schlummern zur Bildung von Persönlichkeitsprofilen zu nutzen und da muss man tatsächlich sagen, das ist ähm kann man eigentlich nur als.
Delusion bezeichnen, denn die Idee hatte vorher schon jemand, nämlich spätestens der Erfinder von Facebook. Äh da das Bilden von Persönlichkeitsprofilen
Und die Nutzung GINA-Persönlichkeitsprofile zur ähm,
Ausspielung zielgerichteter Werbung, nichts geringeres ist als das Geschäftsmodell des Unternehmens,
Insofern ähm bin ich auch jetzt wieder von dieser äh von der Berichterstattung ein bisschen enttäuscht,
weil wir hier sehr viel also da wird dieser Whistleblower, der dann da spricht, da komme ich auch gleich nochmal zu, wird irgendwie als Ginnie
irgendwie den heiligen Gral, der wo die Wunderwaffe der politischen Beeinflussung und niemand zuvor war in der Lage die Big Five vorherzusagen aus äh aus äh Facebook Profilen. Dazu habe ich in der zweihundertdrei schon relativ viel erzählt.
Ähm,
nein, das stimmt einfach nicht. Also hatte ich glaube ich auch in der zweihundertdrei erzählt die Forschung zu dem Thema ist äh so alt, die hat äh stattgefunden, als ich noch ähm,
Noch kein Diplom in Psychologie hatte. Ähm ich habe einen solchen äh Studien auch mitgewirkt und habe da auch mal
das ein oder andere Paper zu gelesen und kenne auch die Forscher, die das gemacht haben. Das ging also sehr viel früher los und ist jetzt wirklich keine,
keine Offenbarung, ähm was da stattgefunden hat
Deswegen kommen wir mal zum Kern, dass der Konflikt, um den es jetzt hier geht, ist, dass dieses Unternehmen Cambridge Analytica offenbar nicht unter
juristisch, vertretbaren Bedingungen an diese Daten gekommen ist, denn was man ja nicht vergessen darf, ist,
Das Unternehmen, Facebook, der gesamte Wert des Unternehmens Facebook besteht in dem,
Immer weiter wachsenden Datensatz. Weshalb sie den natürlich nur sehr ungerne rausgeben.
Als solchen. Ähm gleichzeitig müssen sie so ein bisschen Schnittstellen ermöglichen, das heißt sie sind stets bemüht dafür zu sorgen, dass ihnen, dass der Daten die Menge der Daten ihre bleiben.
Sie aber unter bestimmten Limitationen
Und Einschränkungen anderen auch den Zugriff darauf ermöglichen. Und zum Beispiel so etwas bauen wie eine Login, will Facebook oder so etwas bauen, wie eben Facebookapplikationen, wo man sich,
einfach quasi anmelden kann für eine Applikation oder etwas macht. Und das war jetzt zum Beispiel hier diese App. Digital Life.
Die eben so ein Persönlichkeitstest äh angeboten hat und die ursprünglich von Psychologieprofessor Doktor Alexander Cogen von der Universität Cambridge,
angeboten wurde und der hat also zweitausendfünfzehn damit offenbar von sehr vielen Menschen legal diese Daten erhoben.
Dazu hatte für die Erhebung dieser Daten hatte er offenbar einen eine Vertragsverhältnis mit Facebook,
ob das jetzt ein Vertrag war oder eine AGB, aber er hatte auf jeden Fall eine App dort registriert,
und dann hat er diese Daten, die damit gesammelt wurden, unter Missachtung der Richtlinien, an Camage Analytica, sowie an den äh Whisleblower, hier Christopher Willi und dessen Unternehmen,
Eu Noja Technologies weitergegeben. Und.
Die haben dann eher also dieser Christopher Willey oder Willi sagt jetzt ähm dass Camage Analtica aktiven Zugriff über die App von Korgen hatte auf fünfzig Millionen Facebook Profile.
Und die da hat eben keine Löschung der Daten stattgefunden, sondern er sagt ganz im Gegenteil ähm.
Er hätte die Facebook hat irgendwie gesagt, so habt ihr die Daten denn jetzt auch gelöscht und dann musste er irgendwie sagen, ja, haben wir. Ne, also so. Ja, also das ist eh auch so eine Sache. Die Löschung von Daten.
Äh was nicht beweisbar.
Nicht beweisbar, ja? Ähm da muss man und das ist auch das, was hier passiert mit rechtlichen,
Ding dran, dass man sagt, du musst sie löschen, wenn du es nicht tust oder wenn sie die Zweckentfremdes nutzt, dann hast du dich eben strafbar und das ist hier eben auch der Fall. Ähm.
Und äh Analytica sagt zu seiner Verteidigung, nee, also als wir erfahren haben, dass die Daten nicht gelöscht wurden sind, haben wir alle betroffenen Daten gelöscht und das äh Facebook gegenüber auch bestätigt
und es gäbe ähm in dieser Zusammenarbeit keine
Nutzung der der Nutzerdaten von dieser App für den Wahlkampf von Donald Trump die hier stattgefunden hat.
Camage Analytica brüstet sich. Das habe ich hier heute noch gar nicht erwähnt damit mehr oder weniger den Brexit und die Wahl Donald Trumps herbeigeführt zu haben, weil sie ja so genial sind. Und in diesem Unternehmen hängt auch der Stephen Benon drin, der ja unser freundlicher,
Populist und allseits beliebter.
Zweitausend Azi.
Nazi ist, ne? Ähm jetzt gibt es.
Also erstens muss man natürlich sagen, so diese zielgerichtete Werbung ist ein großes, gesellschaftliches Problem.
Weil hier im insbesondere im politischen Bereich aber nicht nur dort unterschiedliche Ansprache ermöglicht wird von definierten Personengruppen, dass ich also sage, okay, ich präsentiere,
Potenziellen Halloween Hillary Clinton Wählern,
andere Botschaften als potenziellen Donald Trump Wählern und unter den potenziellen Donald Trump Wählern unterscheide ich sage ich mal goldenen Sexmitarbeiter von ähm.
Landbewohnern, die unterschiedliche,
politische Schwerpunkte haben und richte mich jeweils mit der Botschaft an sie, die für mich am naheliegendsten ist. Insbesondere also an Halloween Hillary Trump, Hillary Clinton Wählern mit Botschaften, die sagen, wähl,
Hillary Clinton nicht oder lieber gar nicht? Ähm und And.
Weil sie ist ja böse und.
Und ihr habt einen eigenen E-Mail-Server gehabt und ähm,
um so eben die potenziellen Clinton Supporter einfach der Wahl fernzuhalten und gar nicht erst zu versuchen, sie davon zu überzeugen, Donald Trump zu wählen. Und somit konnte man eben dann in seiner Wahlwerbung ein multidimensionales Feld aufmachen, das sich einer öffentlichen Kontrolle,
entzieht. Ja, wenn man nämlich.
Ist nicht wie so ein Wahlplakat auf der Straße, was alle genau in dieser einen Form sehen, sondern jeder kriegt da quasi seinen persönlich auf, ihn oder sie zugeschnittenes Wahlplakat nur in dem Kontext angezeigt und man weiß halt gar nicht, was wo kommt.
Genau. Jetzt sagen, jetzt gibt's, wird über diesen Fall diskutiert, dass eben hier ein offenbar ein,
Missbrauch der Facebookdaten durch Cambridge Analytica unter Verstoß gegen die Datenschutzbestimmungen von Facebook stattgefunden hat. Jetzt wird darüber berichtet und gesagt ja es gab ein Daten liegt bei Facebook,
Facebook, nein, das ist kein Datenleck, die wir durften diese Daten ja freigeben. Wir haben es ja auch absichtlich gemacht. Es ist hier ein Regelverstoß, der hier die äh der hier stattgefunden hat.
Und jetzt sagt Facebook, sie verklagen jeden, der sagt, es hätte ein Datenleck bei ihnen gegeben und äh das Ganze ist also jetzt hier sehr, sehr,
sehr sehr durcheinander, auf jeden Fall die demokratische Partei der USA wollen also jetzt irgendwie das untersuchen und
Zuckerberg einladen und ihn anhören in Großbritannien hat Facebook sich die Datenschutzbeauftragte Elizabeth Denhem eingetreten, die jetzt eine eigene Untersuchung angekündigt hat. Ähm,
der.
Äh Chef von Cambridge Analytica Alexander Nicks wird wegen einer angeblichen Falschaussage im Parlament unter Druck geraten, weil er nämlich wie gesagt hat, sie hätten nicht mit,
diesen Daten gearbeitet und sich jetzt rausstellt, dass doch ähm,
und in in den USA könnte Facebook eine massive Geldstrafe bekommen, weil sie nämlich ähm zweitausendelf, Ende zweitausendelf strenge Datenschutzregeln,
ausgerollt haben, nachdem die FTC Fedal Trade Commission ähm zu dem Schluss gekommen war, dass sie die Datenschutzversprechen, die sie geben, nicht halten.
Ähm und die Nutzer sich seitdem explizit einverstanden erklären müssen, wenn ihre Daten über die Vorgaben der Standarddatenschutzrichtlinien hinaus verarbeitet werden,
Das ist offenbar hier nicht der Fall gewesen, dass diese fünfzig Millionen Nutzer der App äh Disco Digital Life dem zugestimmt haben, dass diese Daten von Cambridge Analytica genutzt werden,
Und da könnte jetzt theoretisch bis zu vierzigtausend US-Dollar Strafe äh anfallen pro Einzelfall. Das wären also äh viel Geld ähm,
wenn.
Zwei Milliarden Dollar.
Und so weiter.
Das das wäre auf jeden Fall meine Hausnummer. Wird aber wahrscheinlich nicht passieren.
Genau, die Diskussion geht jetzt aber wieder mal tatsächlich am Kern der Sache vorbei, nämlich dass Facebook diese Daten hat,
dass Facebook ein Vielfaches dieser Daten hat und dass völlig scheißegal ist, ob irgendwie ein paar durchgeknallte Hanseln ähm,
mal fünfzig Millionen oder zwar insgesamt zweihundertsiebzig Millionen Facebookprofile äh nutzen.
Um da irgendwie Senatigins zu machen mit mit Wahlmanip Wahlwerbung, was auf jeden Fall ein Problem ist das größere Problem ist aber bilde Facebook sowieso,
Das ist nämlich ein Unternehmen gibt, was Milliarden von Nutzer hat und über Milliarden von Nutzern dieses sehr detaillierte Wissen sammelt und das da jeden Tag reingefüttert wird. Und insofern ist hier ähm,
ist es schwer nachvollziehbar ähm warum jetzt hier von warum man Cambridge Analytica bast.
Die einfach nur eine Facebook AP genutzt haben, die jedem anderen Unternehmen dieser Erde genauso zur Verfügung gestanden hätte und da im Gentlemans,
mal die AGBs nicht ganz so ernst genommen haben. Wie es wahrscheinlich kein anderes Unternehmen dieser Erde jemals in Erwägung ziehen würde,
Insofern ähm sowie das Thema hier diskutiert wird und wie das äh auch in Guardien aufbereitet wurde
ne, wieder iMade, Steve Benance, Psychological, Fairtool, meet the data wow, Whisleblower,
und dann irgendwie derart rote Haare, Wahnsinn, der sitzt der hat mit siebenundzwanzig schon eigenes Einkommen gehabt und nicht mehr bei Mutter gewohnt. Also das ist alles irgendwie es wird hier nicht über das
über der, über das tatsächliche Problem gesprochen ähm,
sondern oder nicht um das um das Grunde liegende Problem, sondern über diesen Einzelfall, der sicherlich schwerwiegend ist, aber das Problem ist, diese Daten sind in der Welt und die werden auch in Zukunft missbraucht werden.
Ja, es gibt alles ähm,
Trotzdem finde ich jetzt diese gehobene Aufmerksamkeit auf den Fall Cambridge Analytica ganz okay. Einerseits, weil die ganz offensichtlicher ähm,
Sagen wir mal auch sehr viel von diesen äh korrupten Stereotypen, die ihnen unterstellt werden auch erfüllen. Es gab ja jetzt noch diesen Bericht da bei Channel vor ähm Britischer Sender, ne? Genau.
Wo sie äh mit diesem Alexander Nix dem Chef von Cambridge Analytica zusammengesessen haben. Die haben sich halt die Journalisten haben sich als potentielle Kunden
politischen Umfeld ausgegeben und dann hat er mal schön
erzählt, was man da so machen kann. Ja, da müssen wir hier nochmal eine andere Firma äh gründen, weil es darf ja dann mit uns nicht in Verbindung stehen und das
darf er den Leuten nicht wie Propaganda rüberkommen, weil wenn sie dann das Gefühl haben, dass es ja Propaganda, dann fragen sie ja auch gleich, wem nutzt das.
Also, der hat da wirklich bemerkenswert, ja, dass,
der sozusagen bei der Öffentlichkeit, die das Unternehmen jetzt schon äh hat, immer noch bereit ist, äh in dem Maße auch äh dritten gegenüber aufzutreten, aber das zeigt halt eben sehr schön, erstens.
Analytica ist wahrscheinlich austauschbar. Ja? Leute, die sozusagen solche Gelegenheiten einfach nutzen werden, wenn sie sich bieten, die
wachsen einfach nach. Das äh ist einfach da. Deswegen machen sich ja auch Datenschützer schon einig von Anfang an genau darum Kop, ne? Das immer sozusagen in dem Moment, wo Daten anfallen, können sie eben auch missbraucht werden und das ist eben jetzt,
meine kann man ein noch krasseren Fall konstruieren als denen, die,
zweitausendsechzehn gehabt haben, ne. So, von daher ist das alles äh nachvollziehbar und ich finde, diese Geschichte hat auch hier Aufmerksamkeit äh verdient,
Natürlich ist das eigentliche Problem, Facebook, weil da kommen ja diese Daten her, da werden sie äh erfasst, da werden sie erhoben und gespeichert,
Und ich sage ja auch mal wieder, also wenn äh Mark Zuckerberg, den ich ja moralisch sowieso im schwierigen Terrain verorte äh irgendwas aus dieser Trump-Wahl äh gelernt hat für sich, ist so ähm,
Also um Präsident zu werden, brauchen wir eigentlich nur zwei Sachen, ne? Geld und Facebook.
Und wenn er sich dann mal im Spiegel anschaut, wird er feststellen, davon hat er jeweils eine ganze Menge,
ehrlich gesagt ich wäre nicht überrascht wenn der Typ tatsächlich mal zu Präsidentenwahl antritt.
Ich sage nicht, das wird geschehen, ich sage nicht. Ja, das ist jetzt ein äh von langer Hand geplant oder was weiß ich.
Nur so mit ähm Weltherrschaft und so weiter äh kennt man sich aus. Er war ja letztes Jahr auch schon ganz gut unterwegs und hat so in Amerika überall so Orte besucht und so.
Er hätte dann sozusagen ein Werkzeug, wo ein echtes Gruseln kommt, da ist dann sozusagen der Besitz von Fox News, wird geradezu antik.
Weil gegen die Power von Facebook kommt wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal Foxdürz an und.
Ähm es brodelt allerdings auch bei Facebook ähm der Sicherheitschef von Facebook ist jetzt zurückgetreten,
weil eben die ähm mit all dem natürlich verbundene Diskussion um was hat Facebook getan, um zu verhindern, dass die Russen Einfluss nehmen auf die,
Wahl beziehungsweise,
was hat Facebook seitdem das bekannt ist und seitdem diese Diskussion angeschwollen ist, unternommen, um das in Zukunft äh in andere Bahnen zu lenken,
Damit war er wohl sehr unzufrieden, fühlte sich von seinen Vorgesetzten, also vor allem Zuckerberg und der Sherry äh Sandburg da an der Stelle äh ziemlich allein gelassen und hat jetzt einfach mal gesagt, mit mir nicht,
also unklar, äh wie weit das jetzt noch los eskaliert, aber,
Zumindest ziehen sich mal so ein paar Wolken zusammen über diese ganzen äh Facebook Geschichte. Ähm.
Der Aktienkurs ist erstmal gemütlich um sieben Prozent eingebrochen.
Ja gut, ich meine Aktienkurse, die steigen auch wieder und so, ne? Also man muss sich natürlich auch.
Wir haben immer eine extreme Fokussierung natürlich, weil wir so primär den Blick natürlich auf die westliche Welt haben auf Facebook so, ne? Aber es gibt natürlich in äh in Russland und in äh China vergleichbare Netzwerke, teilweise.
In dem Land natürlich noch mit einer viel größeren Verbreitung als Facebook und.
Kann man sich in etwa vorstellen, wie der Datenzugriff dort äh aussieht,
Das Problem ist natürlich, dass wir hier natürlich mit Verfestigung von von etablierten Machtstrukturen haben, ne? Also wer halt äh äh erster den den Zugriff auf diese Daten bekommt.
Und damit eben auch um den auf den Nachrichtenfluss bekommen, der wird aus dieser Kette sehr wieder sehr schwer zu entfernen sein.
Facebook hat außerdem äh natürlich also die die kämpfen jetzt aus genau diesen Gründen um ihren Ruf,
Haben jetzt irgendwie Cabrice Analytica, den Mutterkonzern SCL Group, den Professor Cogan, den Whisleblower, Willi oder Willi und äh,
neuer Technologies äh ausgeschlossen, so das damit ist das Problem jetzt erledigt, also.
Junoja.
Unoja you know.
Ja, ich. Du kennst dich.
Keine Ahnung, da habe ich so reingelesen, ne?
Ausgeschlossen. Man muss ja sagen so also ein Blog von Facebook ist ja im Moment sowieso offenbar das Problem von allen Lösungen. Insofern würde auch hier die Lösung des Problems,
angewendet. Gleichzeitig ähm
bettet sich dieses ganze Thema natürlich ein. Äh die USA haben äh fünf russische Organisationen und neunzehn Individuen mit Sanktionen belegt. Ähm im Rahmen dieser Maler
Untersuchung, die ja nach wie vor destruktive Cyberattacken, Angriffe auf kritische Infrastruktur und die Einmischung in die US Präsidentschaftswahl.
Untersucht und äh russischen Akteuren zum Vorwurf macht. Das heißt, dieses Thema ist alles andere als ähm,
Als klein und es bleibt net auf jeden Fall. Camage Analytica ähm vorzuwerfen, dass das, was sie da getan haben, illegal erfolgt ist und leider Gottes das, was Facebook tut. Offenbar immer noch äh von von uns geduldet wird,
Und damit auch legal ist.
Ja. Gibt's da noch viel zu.
Nee, also ich finde, man sollte nur, man sollte sich nur nicht davon blenden lassen, dass dieses Problem jetzt mit dem Ausschluss von Cabrio Analytica äh erledigt sei,
und Camage Analytica ist hier das Symptom aber nicht das.
Problem.
Nicht das zu Grunde liegende Problem. Und ähm ja, also ich bin wirklich so ein bisschen überrascht, wie wie in diesen Artikeln immer so getan wird so also
es diesen Cambridge Analytical Leuten ähm irgendwie die als Genies oder sowas darzustellen, weil sie teilweise jahrzehnte alte, psychologische Forschung, nämlich die,
Bildung von Gesellschaft, äh, von Persönlichkeitsprofilen. Hier mal in die praktische Anwendung gebracht haben,
Das äh hat nichts mit Genie zu tun, sondern was äh damit zu tun, dass sie eben einfach nur asozial genug waren, das was andere Leute schon vor Jahren und Jahrzehnten erforscht hatten, hier mal
in eine konkrete Anwendung zu bringen und,
den tatsächlichen Effekt, den sie erzielt haben, wird man noch sehr viel später irgendwann einmal auseinanderklamüsern müssen,
Und ich glaube, dass es auch, es ist auf jeden Fall ein,
großes Risiko, was sie da tun. Es ist moralisch falsch und ist eine gesellschaftliche Herausforderung, dass das möglich ist. Wir werden uns darüber Gedanken machen müssen. Äh man wird sich aber äh genauso wenig jetzt darauf versteifen können zu sagen,
Oh mein Gott
jemand hat über Facebook die ganze Welt getauscht, äh, getäuscht und uns und ist fortan für jegliches ungemach verantwortlich, auch wenn Camage Analytica das selbstverständlich zu ihrer eigenen Werbung.
Sagt,
und ganz ohne Zweifel das was sie tun nicht akzeptabel ist und wir dagegen kämpfen müssen und wir sicherstellen müssen, dass so etwas nicht passiert, mahne ich aber an, dass bisher keiner weiß, wie stark dieser Effekt wirklich war.
Und da glaube ich wir erfahrungsgemäß,
sind solche Effekte nicht ganz so groß, wie man sie vermutet. Das muss wieder in Verhältnis gesetzt werden zu, mit wie wenig Stimmen heutzutage Wahlen gewonnen werden. Ähm, ich denke, da ist es zu früh,
ein abschließendes Urteil zu fällen, aber dieses ganze Wunderwaffegelaber und so, das ist dann doch schon ähm ein bisschen anstrengend.
Gut. Machen wir da erstmal ein vorläufigen Strich drunter,
Dann wird geklagt. Die Freunde bei der GFF,
Der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte äh klagt gegen Bea. Ähm hatten wir ja hier in Lokbuch, Netzpolitik zwo vier zwo,
Titel, den man gar nicht so ohne Weiteres aussprechen kann. Hat mir das ja ausführlich dargestellt.
Was da so das Problem ist mit ähm diesem Bärsystem, also diesem,
vorgeschriebenen Kommunikationssystem für Anwälte, zur Kommunikation mit Gerichten und da die Brack,
die äh,
Rechtsanwaltskammer äh bisher nicht garantieren kann, ähm diese gebotene sichere Kommunikation, die gefordert ist mit äh Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung über BA äh einzurichten
sieht sich die GFF jetzt genötigt sie zu verklagen um im Interesse aller Mandantinnen und Mandanten das anwaltliche Berufsgeheimnis,
zu schützen.
Also spezifisch geht's um die mangelnde Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung. Also durch das Umschlüsseln äh was sie da ja machen, um äh die Weiterverteilung der Nachricht.
Was vorhin schon hat mit dem Proxim, die aus völlig dargelegt hat, ne?
Genau, sie machen im Prinzip das, was der, was wir mit dem man in der Mittelproxi gerade beschrieben haben, mit jeder Nachricht, ähm um,
sicherzustellen, dass eben ein Anwalt mal seinen Kie verlieren kann äh und dass eine Nachricht mehrere Empfänger erhalten, obwohl sie nur an einer Adresse oder an einen Key gesendet wurde und ähm all das macht man
eben gemütlich. All das ist kein Problem, wenn man keine Verschlüsselung hat und deswegen,
machen sie eben auch keine, beziehungsweise machen das mit dem Umschlüsseln. Und ja, sie machen da einen zentralen, männenden Mittelangriff auf jegliche
Kommunikation zwischen Mandantinnen und Mandanten zwischen Anwälten
zwischen Anwälten und Gerichten ähm und das ist äh nicht einfach nicht akzeptabel,
Und das ist auch ähm glaube ich hier hat Aussicht auf Erfolg. Es ist natürlich auf eine Weise.
Bedauerlich, dass hier überhaupt eine Klage notwendig wird, ähm dass man also nicht auf anderem Wege.
An Einsicht gelangt, insbesondere bei den Rechtsanwälten, wo man sich denkt so, na ja, ihr müsstet doch schon grob verstanden haben, was irgendwie,
Teil eure, was euer Vertrauensverhältnis bedeutet und Kommunikationssicherheit und hasse alles nicht gesehen,
Aber ähm daher erinnere ich mich auch an meine äh,
Wann war das denn auch vor vielen Jahren? Äh Sachverständigenauskunft zum E-Government-Gesetz, wo ich also sagte, hier ähm ihr müsst hier eine, das weiß ich, bevor es überhaupt dieses
gab, äh, da was ging's noch um Däme, wo ich sagte, okay, ihr müsst hier eine Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung sicherstellen und nichts anderes und da war einer der anderen Sachverständigen, da sagte die eine Klage äh,
kann ich auch auf 'ner Postkarte einreichen. Und dann hab ich ihm gesagt ja trotzdem würden Sie das nicht mit einer Web DE Grußkarte machen,
Und äh es war also es ist tatsächlich erstaunlich, dass unter den Juristen,
hier der Bedarf in weiteren Teilen nicht gesehen wird.
Weil mir gerade einfällt, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich so schlagfertig war und das wird der Web DE Grußkarte in der Anhörung gesagt habe oder nur hier im Log.
Das reicht ja auch. Wir sind ja hier Leitmedium.
Ja, waren auf jeden Fall, hier werden mehr Leute dabei als bei dieser Anhörung. Ja, aber es ist wirklich auch bedauerlich, dass man das hier offenbar eine Klage von der GFF angestrengt werden muss.
Ähm und mal wieder eigentlich glaube ich ganz gute.
Ich freue mich, was jetzt das Ziel dieser Klage ist.
Na das Ziel dieser Klage ist natürlich äh also.
Festzustellen, dass sie aktuelle Lösungen nicht ausreichend ist.
Festzustellen, dass die aktuelle Lösung äh nicht akzeptabel ist, hier auf eine zeitgemäße Lösung hinzuwirken und wenn man nicht durch, wenn man mit dem Zuckerbrot, der Sexiness einer zeitgemäßen Lösung äh nicht zum Ziel kommt
dann,
Muss man eben die Peitsche nehmen. Gleichzeitig muss man ja auch wissen, die Anwender dieses dieser Bea Software werden eben größtenteils Anwälte sein, Anwälte sind in der Lage, dieses Crowdfunding relativ flux mal eben,
auf die Beine zu stellen, denn die GF bittet um Unterstütz.
Also für die GF.
Helfen Sie.
Dach schon jetzt fürs nächste Bär.
Nee, also du musst diese Klage unterstützen, das ist im Prinzip ein Aufruf zur äh finanziellen Unterstützung. Ja, da soll sich also eintragen, sagen, ich unterstütze die E-Mail-Adresse und Geldbetrag.
Übrigens, da ist mir noch ein kleiner Bug auf der Seite eingefallen, wenn man auf diesem Feld, wo der Geldbetrag steht, ähm, scrollt, ne? Dann kann man auch in negative Bereiche scrollen, also man kann da so dran drehen, ne? Den Betrag hochschieben.
Oh, kriegt man dann auch Geld überwiesen.
Ich wollte mal gucken, ob ich nicht vielleicht einen Zehner.
Rausholen kann.
Zehner rausholen. Nee, wird natürlich nicht gehen, weil in dem Moment, wo sie die ich glaube nicht, dass du einen Geldeinzug machen kannst und dann, aber vielleicht, ich.
Nehmen sie Kreditkarte? Nee, Ivan und Big. Nee, wird nicht.
Viele große Hackfälle äh begonnen mit. Ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen, dass sie nicht daran gedacht haben, dass.
Sie sagen, also die, äh, jeder Euro zählt, die GFF wird die Spenden erst einziehen, wenn die Fundingschwelle von fünfundzwanzigtausend Euro erreicht ist
sollte ein Teil der Spenden nicht für das BEA-Verfahren gebraucht werden, so wird die GFF sie für andere satzungsgemäße gemeinnützige Zwecke verwenden. Das heißt,
ne, nehmen halt hier, nehmen das auch äh als Stand, also als Fenster für eine allgemeine Unterstützung der Organisation.
Ich denke, dass sie relativ schnell äh das zusammenbekommen. Sie haben ja auch hier äh einige prominente Unterstützer. Unter anderem äh den Rechtsanwalt Thomas Stadler, dessen Einlassung, der ja hier auch regelmäßig ähm,
mit äh im im Lokbuch behandeln. Äh Halina, Waffzeniak, äh, Konstantin von Nord sind jetzt so die äh prominenteren,
Initiatorinnen und Initiatoren, die das hier diesen Aufruf hier mit unterstützen,
und äh da bin ich jetzt also mal,
denke ich, dass Dieper Mark werden ein paar Anwälte wahrscheinlich noch übrig haben und äh es wäre auch schön, hier auch mal äh,
proaktiv an die Nummer ranzugehen und da einfach eine recht, weißt du, wenn sie's nicht freiwillig machen, dann muss man sie halt verklagen, das kennen Anwälte auch nicht anders.
So kennst du das Gefühl, Sonntagmorgens beim Frühstückstisch, wenn man mal einen Krieg gewinnen möchte, da hilft nur Hack und Back.
Knack und Hack.
Hack und Back. Ja. Gibt's jetzt bei der Cyberwehr die ist mal eben schnell am Start. Während die Brötchen noch im Toaster liegen. Wird zurückgehackt.
Was da los? Bundeswehr will jetzt irgendwie Hybrid an Start gehen.
Hybride Kriegsfeuerung ist, dass Bassword bei der Cyberware Cyberware dieses Jahr.
Also sie machen Country und Western.
Country und Western. Hybride kriegst du und ich habe mich da äh vor wenigen Tagen noch mit einem äh Experten zu unterhalten. Ähm,
Hybrid heißt also in diesem Fall auch andere Mittel, wobei noch nicht so ganz klar ist, was diese anderen Mittel sind. Ähm im Prinzip also die Sorge, dass ähm.
Ein eine kriegerische oder eine kämpferische Auseinandersetzung zwischen Staaten.
Nicht mehr nur die Waffen beinhaltet, sondern unter Umständen eben auch so etwas wie Propaganda,
Ein Mischung. Angriffe oder Eingriffe in kritische Infrastrukturen.
Und da setzt sich also die NATO jetzt mit auseinander, dass sie sagen, na ja, wie sieht's denn aus, wenn bei uns,
Cyber, Cyberware äh kommt. Ne, oder wie sieht's, wie gehen wir damit um, wenn wir Ziel von,
Von bösen, finanzierten Propaganda,
ähm Kampagnen werden. Ja, also natürlich ganz offensichtlich hier im Bilde der Gedanke, dass,
Donald Trump, Wahlsieg, dass zum Teil befördert wurde durch,
eine russische Unterstützung, Finanzierung, propagandistische Maßnahmen, ne? Die USA kennen sich damit sehr gut aus, ähm, da sie damit ja auch eine langjährige Tradition haben, so etwas zu tun in anderen Staaten,
Ähm.
In diesem Falle aber natürlich Russland hat noch nicht einmal ein spezifisch wahrscheinlich was davon, ob jetzt Trump oder Hidory Clinton gewinnt, sondern allein schon,
Gewinn dadurch, dass das Vertrauen in die
demokratischen Institutionen über untergraben wird. Ähm! Aber solche, über solche Sachen macht man sich also jetzt Gedenken, Gedanken.
Und ähm da gibt's also eine Cyberabwehrübung der NATO äh gab es zweitausendsiebzehn, wo sie sich also mit technischen Einzelaspekten,
befasst haben, da hat die Bundeswehr teilgenommen, es ist darum gegangen Verfahren und Prozesse für den Schutz von Computernetzwerken zu üben,
Wenn also Webseiten verunstaltet werden, Falschmeldungen verbreitet werden, Benutzernamen und Daten gestohlen werden und ähm
Hier also die oder Drohnen gehackt werden, Energieversorgung ausgeschaltet wird. Also all das, was im weitesten Sinne unter diesem Buzzword Cyberwar
Cyberware. Ähm.
Zusammengefasst wird und zwar deswegen unter dem Wort Cyber Award zusammengefasst wird, weil es kaum noch gesellschaftliche Aspekte gibt, die wir nicht in auf die ein oder die andere Weise äh versibert haben.
Um jetzt den Begriff mal äh bisschen zu strapazieren.
Übermäßig viel zur Anwendung zu bringen. Einfach mal krankes.
So und jetzt gab es, gibt es seit Längerem schon die Debatte. Ähm.
Dass die Bundesregierung prüft, ob es zur Abwehr von Cyberaktak,
auch die Möglichkeit eines Gegenangriffs geben sollte. Das war schon äh letztes Jahr ähm Thema,
Ähm da ist aber nichts mehr weiter passiert und da wir jetzt wieder eine Regierung haben, können die dem da weitermachen.
Also Idee geben wir unserer Bundeswehr die rechtliche Grundlage für ein Hackback.
Und.
Argumentation ist hier eben zu sagen, okay, wenn wir Angriff sind, angegriffen werden, dann wollen wir uns verteidigen. Und da fällt mir ein, also da dazu fällt mir,
Spezifisch ein, dass die immer wieder sehr stark rudern, um überhaupt zu erklären, was denn ein Hugbug Szenario wäre.
Und dann sagen sie irgendwie so Beispiel, ein Botnetz macht einen, die Nile of Serviceangriff auf ein.
Eine kritische Infrastruktur und jetzt machen wir äh Hack und Back mit dem Command in Control Server und sorgen dafür, dass dieser Angriff endet.
Okay, das ist jetzt so eines der.
Da stellt man sich so einen Feuerturm irgendwie im mitten der Cyberlandschaft vor, der irgendwie überall irgendwas hinschießt.
Genau, die fahren dann mit dem Löscheimer in die Kohle, gießen, löschen den Kommando Control Server. Ähm.
Das ist natürlich jetzt, müsste man sich überlegen, okay, nehmen wir dieses Szenario und überlegen mal, ob das wirklich die Maßnahme wäre, so. Ähm was machst du üblicherweise im im Falle von Dinale of Serviceangriffen, die da auf Serviceangriff, also aus vielen,
aus vielen Teilen des Internets kommen Datenpakete in deine Richtung, diese Datenpakete sorgen, entweder durch ihre Scheremenge oder durch das, was sie an.
Computing bei dir auslösen für ein Problem, ja? Ähm,
gerne kommen diese dich überflutenden Datenpakete von.
Internetteilnehmenden, die nicht unbedingt davon wissen, dass sie Teil dieses Angriffs sind. So zum Beispiel bei einer
bei Botnetzangriffen, ja? Also Mirai als Beispiel oder im Falle von sogenannten Reflection-Angriffen, wie wir sie jetzt in den letzten Wochen gesehen haben, unter zur Hilfenahme von Mem Cash
Äh wo du also einen Dienst hast, der auf dem Server läuft, der äh über UDP erreichbar ist.
Wo du die Möglichkeit hast ähm weil es UDP ist und ich TCP eine ein Paket hinzuschicken und zu behaupten, es käme von einer anderen Absendeadresse,
was zur Folge hat, dass die Antwort an deine gesproofte Absenderadresse geht. Und diese äh Emplification-Angriffe nutzt du in dem Fall, wenn du die Möglichkeit hast, durch eine kleine Anfrage,
eine möglichst um mehrere Faktoren einen großen Faktor größere Antwort zu bekommen.
Macht man beispielsweise mit DNS,
Ja, du stellst eine DNS-Anfrage und dann ist die Antwort, die auf diese DNS-Anfrage kommt, ist regelmäßig halt um Faktor, was weiß ich, drei bis sieben größer,
ja? Beim Mem Cash hattest du aber jetzt den Fall, dass du irgendwie sowas wie Faktor,
hundert oder oder fünfhundert erreichen konntest oder so. Also sehr, sehr groß, sehr viel größere Antworten und das ermöglicht es dir als Angreifer einfach die ganze Zeit mit gefälschter Absendeadresse, Anfragen an irgendwelche Memcashes da draußen zu schicken,
gucken auf die gefälschte Absendeadresse sagen, ah okay, ich nehme mal hier meine,
Zehnmal, hundertmal, tausendmal so große Antwort und schickt die einen Absender zurück mit dem Ergebnis, dass die dann bei dir bei diesem ein Ziel.
Das ist so, als wenn du so einen so einen Bleistift auf so ein Feld von äh gespannten Mausefallen draufwirfst irgendwie.
Genau, aber die schnacken halt alle um den Finger von einem dann nachher, ja? Und das äh damit haben wir jetzt gerade in den letzten Wochen wieder die historisch größten.
Ähm die Nile of Serviceangriffe gehabt, also der Rekord von Mirai wurde gebrochen, weil es jetzt eben Terabit-Angriffe durch Mem Cash die äh Reflection Angriffe gab,
Langer Rede, kurzer Sinn, in einer solchen Situation musst du natürlich irgendwie diese Dinale auf Serviceangriff in den Griff kriegen. Üblicherweise machst du das, indem du Netzwerkseitig filterst,
Also sagst okay ähm wir gehen so nah so weit wie möglich von unserem Ziel weg an zentrale Punkte, sei es jetzt,
Am Eingang zu unserem Datenzentrum und fangen dort an mit Filterregeln, diese Dinite auf Serviceangriffe irgendwie in den Griff zu bekommen, indem wir diese Pakete ablehnen,
Wenn du da jetzt von Terrabit redest, ist das natürlich zugegebenermaßen irgendwann sehr schwierig, weil,
Selbst dein Datenzentrum kein unter Umständen keine Terrabidanbindung hat, das heißt ein ganzes Datenzentrum wird vom Internet abgeschlossen abgeschlossen. So, jetzt sagen sie, okay, in einer solchen Situation wollen wir also.
Die den Ursprung des Angriffes hacken, um dafür zu sorgen, dass der Angriff aufhört.
Aber der Ursprung ist überhaupt nicht sichtbar, weil man weiß überhaupt nicht, was die ganzen Maschinen dazu gebracht hat, in eine andere Richtung zu feu.
Genau, jetzt könntest du natürlich sagen, okay, wir gucken mal auf den auf den Traffic, der zu diesen Maschinen geht und versuchen herauszufinden, woher diese UDP Pakete kommen.
Die gesprooft werden, das heißt wir müssen dann uns irgendwie Gedanken machen, die sind ja aber gespooft, also müssen wir irgendwie gucken, wo kommen diese Pakete her und dann finden wir irgendwann
Okay, da ist ein eine internetteilnehmende Maschine, von der diese UDP Pakete ausgehen oder mehrere,
Und dann kommt der äh kommt der äh,
der Kommandeur äh von oben runter zu seinen zu seinen Gefreiten und sagt, hier hack das.
Hack und Back so, ne? Und dann nehmen die Tastatur und hacken das Ding. Ist jetzt in diesem Moment schon wirklich dann äußerst unrealistisch, dass sie innerhalb weniger Minuten.
Oder Stunden hier ein akzeptable Möglichkeit finden,
Dort einen Einstieg zu zu erreichen. Denn so wie es auch beim Bundestags und beim,
Bundesregierungsheck war, sind Angreifer früher schon drin. Es ist nicht so, dass du spontan mal losgehst und sagst, alles klar, jetzt hacken wir mal das hier,
In der Regel ist es so, dass ein Angriff vorbereitet sein muss. Vor allem, wenn du jetzt hier unter Umständen nicht nur nur davon redest, einen laufenden Angriff abzuschalten,
sondern wenn du hier davon redest ähm äh,
wie nennt man das? Abschreckendes Potential zu entfalten oder sogar Vergeltung vorzunehmen.
Dann bedeuten, dass man im Prinzip ähnlich aufgestellt sein muss, wie die Angreifer, weil wenn man jetzt sozusagen irgendjemand mit Detox-Attacke nennenswert einschüchtern möchte, so nach dem Motto
Ja, dann müsste man im Prinzip selber so ein Botnetz äh haben, was Sicherheitslücken ausnutzt, was auf Zuruf halt im Prinzip den Spieß umdreht und sagt so, du, du willst Terrabin, kannst du haben, so sind
macht man im Prinzip dasselbe und schon äh kann man halt Zuschauer, wie die Kinder sich im Sandkasten gegenseitig äh verprügeln und keinem ist geholfen.
Und jetzt mag my Words. Ich gehe davon aus, wir werden innerhalb dieser Legislaturperiode dieses Hack und Back bekommen und dann wird es nämlich weil du spezifisch sehr.
Also weil du, weil es sehr schwierig ist zu sagen, dass es nur reaktiv sein darf.
Und zwar auch nur gegen einlaufender Angriff und nur zur Abwendung eines laufenden Angriffs und so weiter, glaube ich nicht, dass sie, dass das am Ende der Gesetzestext sein wird. Der Gesetzestext wird am Ende sein, dass er effektiv der Bundeswehr.
Erlaubt, ähm sage ich mal, kleine Infektionen irgendwo anzubringen und diese nachher äh zur Anwendung zu bringen.
Sein, dass man sich mal wehren muss.
Genau und es gibt eben durchaus Argumente dafür,
Und das sind die, die quasi von so Leuten kommen, die auch schon vorher sehr erfolgreiche Strategien ähm in,
Im militärischen Bereich hatten, denken wir an den gesamten Kalten Krieg, wo äh man sich einfach nur,
jahrzehntelang Milliarden in irgendwelche Weltvernichtenden Waffen gesteckt hat, nur
um den anderen davon abzudem anderen zu zeigen, dass man die auch hat und ihn so davon abzubringen, diese zum Einsatz zu bringen. Eine glorreiche Zeit in der Geschichte der Menschheit. Wir haben selten was Tolleres hingekriegt, um uns allen zu zeigen, wie geil wir sind.
Und ich denke aus dieser, wenn man in dieser Denkweise bleibt, ist es auch relativ klar, dass man eine Abschreckungspotenzial Potential
in dieser Cyberei haben möchte
Das Problem bei solchen äh wenn ein wenn du deine komplette Strategie auf Abwehrpotent äh auf Abschreckungspotential,
fokussierst ist, dass du dein dein defensives Potential nicht wirklich aufbaust.
Und dass sie äh quasi Stadt zu sagen, okay, wir müssen resilienter werden. Wir müssen eben sichere,
Strukturen bauen, wir müssen da halt Hochsicherheit auch mal mit Leben füllen, sagen sie, nee, wir wollen eben lieber,
uns in dieser unsicheren Welt ähm.
Wohlfühlen und eingliedern. Und das Problem, was ich hier für Deutschland sehe, also man muss auch sagen, so, es ist, es wäre auch unrealistisch davon auszugehen, dass ausgerechnet Deutschland oder irgendein anderes Land in der Lage wäre, eine nicht hackbare Infrastruktur zu bauen,
Ja, insofern muss man da auch sagen, ja äh es ist auch verständlich, dass sie sagen, okay, wir bauen ähm,
Wir bauen entsprechend äh auch Abwehrabschreckungspotential auf. Das ist so deren äh Denkweise. Ich glaube aber, dass es das früher oder später eben in in,
wirklich in in Teufelsküche äh bringen wird. Gerade weil Deutschland, wenn man jetzt mal selbst wenn man diese Argumentation folgen will, ähm
Eben ein Land ist das hier weder die Defensiven noch die offensiven Kapazitäten hat und erst recht die Offensiven nicht mehr aufbauen wird,
Das heißt, es gibt in diesem Spielfeld für die Bundesrepublik Deutschland eigentlich nur einen Vorsprung darin.
Ähm durch Komplexitätsreduktion,
Hochsicherheitskonzepte eine Resilienz aufzubauen und so hier in die in die Verteidigung,
gehen, was offenbar der Bundesrepublik Deutschland heute schon nicht gelingt
und es ist doch sehr erstaunlich, wenn du mehr oder weniger drei, vier Wochen, nachdem dir der die Bundesregierung aufgemacht wurde, äh das erste, was unserem guten Helge Braun
jetzt einfällt ist zu sagen oh das müssen wir aber auch machen statt zu sagen OK was ist hier.
Was erlaube IVBB.
Gleichzeitig nur um zu zeigen, dass das Problem eben da ist, aus Saudi-Arabien wird berichtet, es hätte ein.
Einen Hackingangriff gegeben auf ein petrochemisches Unternehmen und die Angreifer äh hätten hier zum Ziel gehabt eine,
Explosion herbeizuführen. Schwachstellen richteten sich auf Geräte des französischen Herstellers Schneider Electric. Die war bei uns auch schon mal Thema. Ich weiß nur nicht mehr genau wieso,
doch schneller Elektrik war ja schon mal Thema.
Wo es eben um in Industrial Controller ging, die
In rund achtzehntausend Fabriken der Welt im Einsatz sind und es wird jetzt davon ausgegangen, dass es sich hier um eine Auseinandersetzung zwischen dem Iran und der und Saudi-Arabien gehandelt hat und äh
die Behörde der Bericht ist, der Angriff habe nur deswegen nicht funktioniert, weil,
sich in dem Angriffscode ein Bug versteckt hätte.
Also hätte im Prinzip hochgehen können, aber ist nicht.
Kann das jetzt so nur zur Kenntnis nehmen, weil es mal wieder ähm recht dürftig ist. Ähm.
Es würde aber jetzt irgendwie so aus der Ferne betrachtet natürlich nicht wundern, nachdem der Iran äh Angriffsziel von Stucksnet war, dass die entsprechende offensive Fähigkeiten auch aufgebaut haben.
Und sagen OK wenn.
Wenn ihr hackt, hacken wir Back.
Dann hacken wir Back. Ja und sowas kommt von sowas bis einer heult.
Was für Zweifelsfall wieder sind.
Ja, genau.
So dann äh ich weiß gar nicht, hatten wir schon mal drauf hingewiesen, ja, ne? Guten Abend. Nicht?
Doch schon. Wird das wieder rausgenommen,
Ähm okay, gut, dann folgendes. Also, es gibt ja Projekt Gutenberg ähm das gibt schon relativ lange, nämlich seit neunzehnhunderteinundsiebzig wird daran gearbeitet ähm.
Bücher, andere Schriftwerke, die deren Urheberrecht abgelaufen ist zu digitalisieren, zu in der äh,
Waisenvoraussicht, dass das äh doch mal ganz hilfreich sein könnte.
Und das Projekt kennen sicherlich viele von euch, das ist äh der Gutenberg-Org. Schon lange online und da haben sich so einige ähm Bücher angefunden,
Ich glaube so an die sechsundfünfzigtausend E-Bücher sind dort,
zu holen. Das Portal kommt auch in verschiedenen Sprachoberflächen und bietet entsprechend auch Werke aus aller Welt,
Jetzt gab es einen ähm ja eine Rechtsauseinandersetzung, die noch anhält des S Fischer Verlags aus Deutschland, der zu Holzbrinken gehört.
Und ähm hat die Verantwortlichen des Portals dort äh darauf hingewiesen, dass ja,
ähm dort urheberrechtlich Material liegt, was in Deutschland eben noch Urheberrechtsschutz genießt, wenn auch in den USA nicht mehr,
Konkret ging's da um Bücher von Heinrich Mann, Thomas Mann und Alfred Dublin und ähm,
andere äh nur mal so zum Vergleich, also in Deutschland gilt ja die Regel siebzig Jahre nach dem Tod der Autoren entfällt dann eben das Urheberrecht. Das ist dann bei den dreien zwanzig zwanzig,
zwanzig fünfundzwanzig und zwanzig siebenundzwanzig. Ja, also ob das jetzt noch,
so groß interessiert, aber es macht wieder mal wunderbar diese diese Absurdität, ja? Also wessen Rechte werden jetzt hier eigentlich auch noch geschützt. Also geht's jetzt da drum, dass die sich nicht weiter im Grab drehen, ja? Weil jemand ihre Bücher liest,
Ja, also ich meine, haben die Angst, Geld zu verlieren, so.
Ich finde das also bei siebzig Jahre nach dem Tod, ne? Ähm.
Also so sieben Jahre nach dem Tod würde ich ja irgendwie noch verstehen können so.
Was ist die durchschnittliche Lebenserwartung? Irgendwie wahrscheinlich irgendwie achtzig Jahre oder sowas in Deutschland. So. Das hei.
Na ja, also in etwa ein, ein, ein, ein Menschenleben lang.
So das heißt, wenn in dreißig Jahren der Tim stirbt.
Und seine Kinder schon über dreißig sind, dann werden diese Kinder noch bis zu ihrem Tod wiederum das Urheberrecht genießen und die Kinder von Teams Kindern auch noch die Hälfte ihres Lebens.
So, das heißt, wenn ihr jetzt hier Logbuch Netzpolitik zweihundertachtundvierzig im Jahr zweitausendeinhundertsiebzehn hört,
dann könnt ihr hoffen, dass ich nicht noch so viel länger gelebt habe, weil ich ja auch noch Urheberrecht habe.
Das dauert also noch so ein bisschen, bis das hier irgendwann mal, bis wir hier irgendwann mal die Rechte an unseren vierzehn Tagen.
Gut, dass Podcast auch noch in fünfhundert Jahren gehört werden.
Dann kann es dann, ist das irgendwann einmal gemeinfrei.
Ja. Ja.
Aber wenn ihr denn auf euren digitalen Gramophonen,
Diese antiquierten äh äh AC-Falls abspielt, dann seid euch gewiss, dass wir hier noch die Rechte dran haben, liebe Freund.
Ja, so rückständig sind wir noch, dass wir unsere Audidateien noch digital verbreitet haben.
Was haben die damals digital gemacht? Das war ein Aufwand.
Krass ey.
Da haben die, die mussten durch das ganze Land kleine Glasfasern leben.
Da haben sich damals schon gefragt, wer das bezahlt.
Hast du einen Aufwand? Anstatt das einfach direkt durch den Eter zu drücken, wie man das schon immer geahnt hat.
Na ja, kommen wir zurück zu dem eigentlichen Fall. Also.
Eigentlich möchte halt dieser Verlag, dass die ihm diese achtzehn beanstandeten Titel gesperrt werden in den USA fand man das Ganze überhaupt nicht so lustig und hat jetzt einfach mal die komplette ähm den das komplette deutsche Portal äh von Gutenberg-Org,
runtergenommen und antwortete einfach nur mit einer flapsigen Seite, so ein bisschen vergleichbar zu der Auseinandersetzung zwischen der GEMA und YouTube,
Lange Zeit immer so dieses Schuld so, hat ja auch super funktioniert. Alle waren dann total,
giftig auf die GEMA, gut, kann man ja vielleicht auch sein, aber das war sozusagen jetzt auch nicht so, dass jetzt hier die Problemlösung ausschließlich bei der GEMA lag, sondern das war ja eben eine ausstehende Einigung zwischen den beiden. Nee, na ja,
Ja ähm.
Na die begründen das halt damit, dass sie sagen, na ja äh also eigentlich würde es ja reichen, wenn sie die achtzehn Bücher sperren,
Und jetzt sagt der äh Nubi, der ähm Chef von Projekt Gutenberg sagt, hey, es ist notwendig, die die deutschen Nutzer komplett auszusperren,
Denn wenn es da die das Gerichtsurteil, was wir uns eingefangen haben, eigentlich nur achtzehn E-Books betrifft, ähm können wir da natürlich äh hätten wir weiterhin die Gefahr, dass wegen anderer Titel geklagt wird. Und nochmal wollen wir das nicht,
Und deswegen äh sperren wir lieber einfach alles. Sperren wir ganz Deutschland aus, weil in Deutschland gibt's diesen verrückten Verlag S Fischer und ähm bevor wir gegen den nochmal verlieren, äh das Risiko geben wir nicht ein. Deutschland ist einfach nicht rechtssicher.
Scheiß auf Deutschland. Die paar.
Müsst ihr in Urlaub fahren oder euch einen VPN klicken, um.
Die auf ihrer Seite sagen sie hier VPN und alles aber alles im Griff irgendwie guckt ihr gar nicht durch. Also.
Halte ich für unwahrscheinlich.
Ja, ich auch, aber es steht auf der Seite,
Na ja gut. Ähm ja. Gibt's da noch viel zu sagen? Sozusagen, ne. War ja eine Kurzmeldung.
Genau.
So, der Papst hat die Flatter.
Der Taff wird flatterhaft vom Internet.
Das Internet gibt den Jugendlichen das Gefühl, Teil einer einzigen großen Gruppe zu sein, äh sagt der Papst,
und äh das Netz lässt die Jugendlichen in der Luft hängen und macht sie daher extrem flatterhaft. Die Jugendlichen von heute wachsen in einer verwurzelten Gesellschaft.
Entwurzeln.
Entwurzelten Gesellschaft auf, ich denke, ein effizienter Weg, uns zu retten, ist das Gespräch, der Dialog zwischen den Jungen und den Alten ein Brückenschlag zwischen der Jungen und der alten Generation. Ja, das war schon immer so. Das hat der Papst gelernt. Ähm.
Ich glaube, das wurde jetzt ja auch nur äh zitiert, weil es der Papst äh gesagt hat.
Ich glaube, der bezieht sich jetzt auch hier auf den Podcast, ne?
Der bezieht sich auf den Podcast.
Weil es ja ein Brückenschlag zwischen der alten und neuen Generation.
Das hast du mir jetzt übel genommen, dass ich gesagt habe, du stirbst vor mir, ne.
Ja, ja.
Wer weiß? Wollen wir mal hoffen, dass.
Werden wir das sehen, genau.
Das ist ja für uns noch äh im in äh erreichbarer Disterne, das mit dem Ewigleben. Habe ich gesehen im Fernsehen.
Jetzt neu, ewig leben.
Ja, aber das habe ich, so geht's fünf Tricks, wie du ewig lebst. Aber ich habe dir doch.
Ja, aber ich habe dir doch keine Milch trinken und durch die nicht durch die Giftnehmer gehen.
Ja. Ich habe aber, glaube ich, dass das Buch ähm Homodeus hier schon mal äh empfohlen, oder?
Weil sie die Hugo Deos.
Homodeus, eines der besten Bücher äh Juwall Harari, heißt der Autor, glaube ich. Ah, äh sei hiermit empfohlen. Habe ich aber bestimmt schon mal empfohlen. Ähm jetzt heißt es, wir fahren nicht vollständig ver.
Warum? Man das warum du das empfehl.
Weil es eines der besten Bücher ist.
Ja jetzt zu welchem Thema? Also inwiefern hat.
Ja, mein, also mein mein Mann hat zu lesen äh äh Sabiens, eine kurze Geschichte der Menschheit,
und Homodeus. Das sind einfach die beiden äh Bücher, die äh sehr, sehr viel über das äh Sein und die Entwicklung äh des Menschen.
Behandeln und daher tatsächlich sehr ähm empfehlenswert sind und so zum absoluten muss man äh gelesen haben, gehören. Auf jeden Fall. Beide von dem gleichen Autor,
Ah ich glaube inzwischen in den USA tätiger.
Forscher, ich müsste jetzt kurz gucken. Wahl.
Ich glaube, dass in Tel Aviv an der Uni oder sowas. Juwa Noah Harari, israelischer Historiker.
Lehrt seit zweitausendfünf in Jerusalem nicht in Tel Aviv, sondern in Jerusalem ähm kurze Geschichte der Menschheit wurde ein internationaler Bestseller und ebenso ist glaube ich, also Homodeus ist wahrscheinlich jetzt noch Bestseller,
Großartige Bücher über die Geschichte der Menschheit, einmal bei äh Sapiens und dann eben in Homodeus, wo er sich
über die ethischen Herausforderungen hinsichtlich Assistenzsystemen erweiterten Kognition, kognitiven Fähigkeiten
äh und unter Umständen der naheliegenden Besiegung äh des Todes durch die Forschung widmet.
Und äh hier ethische äh Fragen und Antworten äh verlangt. Großartig.
Jetzt das sind also tolle Autoren und jetzt haben wir natürlich noch, jetzt haben wir den Papst.
Unser unseren Beitrag dafür, dass ihr das noch erleben dürft, dass diese Sendung Urheberrecht befreit daher kommt.
Genau. Das wollen wir alle noch erleben. Vielleicht aber äh warte mal, das wäre ja unglaublich, wenn wir nicht sterben, dann wird, wenn wird auch das Urheberrecht, also quasi das ist dann Infinit Plus siebzig.
Ja, vor allem, das wird ja in den nächsten fünfzig Jahren auch noch immer noch wieder um zehn Jahre verlängert werden, also der der Zeitpunkt, der,
schwebt sozusagen in die Unendlichkeit.
Unendlich plus eins.
Weil Mickey Maus muss ja geschützt bleiben und deswegen werden wir auch noch achtzig, neunzig und hundert Jahre erleben, weil es ist ganz wichtig, dass die, dass die Wirtschaft schnell reagieren kann, dafür brauchen wir nämlich solche Fressen, die sich
kein Schwein vorstellen kann.
Der der gute,
Papst hat ja hier nur so ein paar Sätze gesagt, wir haben eine entwurzelte Gesellschaft. Ja, also da hat er im Zweifelsfall auch noch nicht mal Unrecht mit und ähm der Papst ähm papstet ähm und,
der äh Manfred Spitzer,
Spitz zu und der hat jetzt auch wieder ein ein schönes äh Buch geschrieben mit dem Titel eine, also hat ja neue, also das erste Buch hieß ja irgendwie, glaube ich, Cyberkrank,
Vorsicht, Bildschirm und digitale Demenz sind so die Bücher von Manfred Spitzer und das ist irgendwie so jemand der sich also ganz ausführlich,
Darüber auslässt, dass die die Kinder alle äh dumm werden und ähm.
Durch das Internet äh eben auch flatterhaft werden und äh äh irgendwie so schön in einem Interview glaube ich dann gesagt, dass äh wir uns durch diese ganze am Internet äh hängen ähm uns eine Generation von,
Von äh Reinigungskräften heranziehen, weil die Leute für nichts anderes mehr äh zu gebrauchen sein werden. Also es ist wirklich geht auf,
keine Kuhhaut.
Wobei das für Berlin ja mal ganz praktisch wäre. Reinigungskräfte ja.
Reinigungskräfte könnten wir gebrauchen, ja. Äh.
Ja, der hat wahrscheinlich zu lange YouTube geguckt auf was der aber da gibt's einen sehr schönen ähm.
Nebel gestanden.
Sehr schöner Artikel von von Christian Stöcker, äh der ähm ja auch sich der äh Psychologe ist, der also auch dieses Fach studiert hat
der wirklich sehr harsche Kritik an dem findet, weil dieser Spitzer da im Prinzip Meinungsbücher verfasst, in denen er Forschungsergebnisse selektiv auswählt und die irgendwie
aufbaust zu irgendwelchen sehr, sehr, sehr provokanten Thesen und das Ganze eben immer dann ja der Hirnforscher Manfred Spitzer, eine Koryphäe auf dem Gebiet und so ähm,
diese diese.
Expertenzuschreibung im in den Medien. Äh das ist ganz.
Expertenzuschreibung dann doch sehr.
Ganz furchtbar. Da gibt's ja auch so einige äh Vögel. Ich will jetzt mal keine weiteren Namen nennen, aber ich hatte da auch selber schon mal äh das Vergnügen, dass ich mal so eine Veranstaltung moderiert habe, wo auch einer von diesen von diesen Internet äh angeblichen Internet
dass man da äh rumhängt, der sozusagen auf jedem dritten Panel irgendwie rumsitzt und man fragt sich, ob sie überhaupt noch irgendwas anderes machen, als nur auf so eine Ding-Pance rumzusitzen und die Antwort ist. Wahrscheinlich nicht
ja und äh von das ganz interessant, weil er mich dann irgendwie so als Moderator so äh vorher so ganz äh in so einer Routine,
so drauf hin, wie's ja hier hören sie mal zu, so also meine Talking Point Dist und Tis. So.
So daran erkennst du den Profi.
Dann irgendwie positioniere ich mich mal so. Also was ja so ein also ich will nicht unbedingt sagen, was ich jetzt besonders überrascht war,
Ich habe nur in dem Moment gemerkt, wie mir das selber überhaupt,
gefiel, ja? Weil ich irgendwie selber in solche solche Auseinandersetzungen solche Debatten ganz anders rein ging. Äh am Ende war ich auch etwas überemotionalisiert, sonst passiert nicht halt immer schlechteste Moderation, die ich je äh abgelegt habe, so aber ähm,
mein Dislike für ähm solche sogenannten Experten, die eigentlich am am Ende unterm Strich einfach,
Alle ihrer Antworten schon vorher wissen, so und nur eine Rolle spielen,
Das ist das, worauf ich hinaus will, ja? Also die schaffen sich sozusagen so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein Erscheinungs äh äh Körper,
und vertreten dann halt einfach die Thesen, weil das in diesen gespielten Diskurs einfach gut reinpasst
So, ja, ich bin dann irgendwie der Typ, der immer am Internet zweifelt, so äh man muss ja auch mal die andere Seite sehen und schon äh sitzt er auf einem heißen Stuhl nach dem anderen und hasser irgendwie dein Auskommen.
Und da kann man ja auch ganz gut von leben von so einem äh Panel Hopping, wenn man's richtig macht. Muss man auch mal so sehen.
Frank Rieger hat das mal in dem Zusammenhang, da haben wir auch über jemanden gesprochen, der äh wieder auf vielen Veranstaltungen war und dann sagte Frank nur so, ja,
Bei dem scheint's wirtschaftlich nicht gut zu laufen. Der muss jetzt wieder auf den Vortragstrich.
Ja, was war denn mit der Kurzmeldung? Wir waren beim Papst.
Also ich mache ja den Papst irgendwie. Ich finde den ja sehr.
Auf jeden Fall cooler als Manfred Spitzer.
Ja und auch irgendwie als andere, alle anderen äh Führer, die der halt so den westlichen und sonstigen Nationen vorstehen
Also da macht er dann irgendwie doch eine ganz gute Figur. Ich weiß nicht, wie erfolgreich er damit sein wird, da äh seinen eigenen Sumpf auszutrocknen, da ist auf jeden Fall auch noch einiges zu tun. Aber ähm.
Ich muss sagen, auch gewisse Dinge sehe ich ihm nach. Also ich finde dafür, dass er einundachtzig ist,
äh ist auch noch ziemlich helle dabei und vertritt ja auch äh durchaus nachvollziehbare Thesen und scheint auch nicht so vollkommen äh unterglockt zu sein von von diesem ganzen
Wirrsinn, der in meinen Augen dieser ganze Religionspuppe ja äh letztlich nur ist,
Ähm trotzdem äh Props irgendwie, Papst äh finde ich gut.
Okay, das lasse ich jetzt einfach mal so.
Also den lasse ich durchgehen.
Der darf noch, der, der darf bleiben.
Der hat der hat Groove irgendwie. Also ich finde, finde, der hat so einen, der hat so einen Vibe irgendwie, von dem, dass ich mir auch mal irgendwie eine eine äh knifflige These machen. Und ehrlich gesagt, ein paar Internet auch total flachhaf.
Ich finde auch ganz platt.
Also Manfred Spitzer ähm wunderschön wie wieder hier mal eben aus fachlicher Perspektive auch auseinandergenommen wird. Äh Chris Stöcke hat sich da die Mühe gemacht, auch mal die
zitierten Studien sich anzuschauen und findet dann eben schnell raus, dass er da irgendwie na die zitierten Studien sind allein auf Weiterflur äh von allen anderen wiederlegt und äh wie was weiß ich der Narzissmus nehme zu äh kann
irgendwie keiner nachweisen. Ähm und das ist wirklich halt einfach alarmistisch und ich finde, da muss ganz ehrlich sagen, dass ich.
Beobachte das,
mit äh mit Missfallen wie inzwischen Probleme nur noch so ins absolute Desaster gerissen werden können. Ähm um sie zu behandeln, ne? Also es geht nicht unter Cambridge Analytica ist,
Untergang der Demokratie.
Ähm Anti-Christ.
Genau. Es geht nicht mehr,
es geht nicht mehr sich mit dem Thema ernsthaft auseinanderzusetzen und ich finde das auch, also es ist überall da dieses Phänomen, es ist vielleicht war es auch schon immer so. Ähm es ist auf jeden Fall sehr schwierig, weil ich das auch natürlich sehe in
zum Beispiel bei so Themen wie wir sie behandeln der Heck von PC Wahl, der Hack des,
besonderen elektronischen Anwalt.
Ist immer gleich der Untergang.
Ja, dass es vor allem sehr, also dass es immer nur in Schwarz-Weiß gedacht wird, ne, dass man sagt, hier ist eine Schrottsoftware und dann, oh mein Gott und ein Schrottsoftware und dann irgendwie oh, sie wurde aber gefixt,
und nicht, dass man nicht einfach mal sagt, so nee, passt auf, es gibt hier ein, es gibt hier ein systemisches Problem, das systemische Problem lautet, diese Software war nicht einsehbar und wir wissen nicht, wer noch was noch alles Schrott ist und wir möchten hier einmal ordentliche Software schaffen und die Gründe dafür sind, folgende.
Das hört dann kaum noch jemand, ne? Das können wir hier mal im Podcast ausrollen. Das können wir äh wenn
Martin Thorsten und ich dann mal ein Vortrag auf dem Kongress halten, in Ruhe ausrollen, aber es kommt auch wirklich bei diesen flatterhaften Jugendlichen nichts anderes mehr an.
Wir sind auch nicht ganz unschuldig,
Ne, guck mal hier, letzte Sendung und so. Internet wird jetzt zurückgebaut. Ja, seid euch da eure Anschlüsse nicht mehr sicher, ja? Die mega Bits werden alle einkassiert, dann kommt halt nämlich der Osterhase und sammelt die alle wieder ein, die Bits.
Halt an deiner TAE-Dose.
Genau, runtergeladene Dateien nochmal sichern, weil die werden jetzt alle von der Platte gepflück.
Wer weiß, wann du nochmal die Bandbreite.
Downloads werden jetzt rückgängig gemacht.
Aber es ist tatsächlich, ne, diese diese Ausweitung,
oder diese Zuspitzung tut uns allen nicht gut und ich glaube das ist wahrscheinlich auch der Grund, warum wir natürlich hier den Trend sehen, dass Blockbuchnetzpolitik immer länger wird,
wir uns immer wieder bemühen die Themen von Anfang an in irgendeiner Weise einzuordnen und da übrigens auch,
Immer wieder der dankbare Hinweis an alle, die uns in den Kommentaren äh äh auf Fehler
hinweisen, die wir dabei machen. Wir wollen unser Ziel ist hier die Aufklärung und das geht eben nur, wenn man sich darüber
Detailgedanken macht und nicht die ganze Zeit nur trommelt.
In Würzburg Komma Fehler sind. Ja. Auf sowas werden wir auch hingewiesen.
Man hört Komma Fehler.
Ja, es gibt ja auch noch eine schriftlich.
Fehlende Links, das ah, das fand ich immer so echt interessant, dass jetzt immer mal wieder auch Feedback kam so, ja da habt ihr einen Link äh irgendwie nicht gesetzt, was ich total krass finde, weil diese Shownotes sind Schweinearbeit,
und ähm ich habe immer den Zweifel gehabt, dass die vielleicht gar nicht geklickt werden die Links, aber das ist nicht der Fall, auch das ist.
Ja, neulich hatte ich auch meine UHL äh kaputt gemacht, so sie wurde dann auch gleich moniert, dass die ja nirgendwo hinführt. Das sind,
unsere kleinen Tricks um zu testen, ob man da auch drauf klickt. Wenn ihr so ein Feedback nicht kommt, dann lassen wir die demnächst komplett weg. Nee, nee.
So bleiben wir bei den Kurzmeldungen. Ähm.
Rodin Gag.
Es war mal wieder Point to one Zeit, also ähm der Hackerwettbewerb bei dem äh,
bei dem es um Browser Sicherheit geht und der eigentlich immer so aufgebaut ist, dass also Teams dort Schwachstellen demonstrieren müssen und dann am Ende eine Prämie dafür bekommen,
dass sie ihren Beitrag zur ähm zur Verbesserung dieses äh Produktes äh geleistet haben. Insbesondere so, dass es deshalb halt ähm wichtig, weil.
Man hiermit eben die die unabhängige Überprüfung von äh Sicherheitsmechanismen durch diese hohen Preisgelder sicherstellt,
Gleichzeitig natürlich diese Preisgelder eben relativ.
Also auch Preise treiben und dafür dazu führen, dass natürlich unter Umständen äh man sagt, ah ja okay, diese Schwachstelle, die ich hier gerade gefunden habe, halte ich,
halte ich lieber für die Ponto One zurück oder verkaufe sie an andere. Deswegen äh betrachten wir inzwischen diese krassen Backbounties natürlich mit einem gemischten Gefühl, solange es aber gleichzeitig diese
ähm diese Preise eben auch,
bezahlt werden von äh Schadi-Teilnehmern des Marktes ist es eben wichtig, dass hier mit solchen Wettbewerben eben auch ähm moralisch, akzeptable,
gut Zahlen der Alternativen geschaffen werden, äh damit es eben ähm auch im Rahmen der Response wird.
Hier Möglichkeiten gibt dickes Geld äh einzusacken und nicht nur indem man es an äh zwielichtige Unternehmen verkauft.
Gleichzeitig auch, weil wir es in der letzten Sendung hatten wieder mal äh Schwachstellen in dem,
Passworttresor von Firefox, äh wo also ein Forscher jetzt äh erneut aufgezeigt hat. So wie der.
Wie der Passwortsafe von von FireFox gebaut ist, ist eben nicht ausreichend äh in wie es heute passiert und deswegen äh,
gibt's also bemängelt, da mehrere Mängel irgendwie äh Verwendung zu schwacher äh Hashverfahren äh zu kleiner äh Sals und ähm,
dass er also sagt, man müsste hier nur so ein äh paar Millionen Hashes pro Sekunde ausprobieren, könnte also hiermit überschaubarem Aufwand doch
durch eine lokale Infektion oder durch einen Trojaner diese Sachen diese diese Passwörter habhaft werden. Ich erwähn das nur, weil wir,
darüber in der vorletzten Folge auch diskutiert hatten. Also Browsersicherheit geht auch voran, merkt euch, bitte. Da müsst ihr immer schön die Updates machen.
Damit ihr da nicht unter die Räder kommt, denn gerade diese Browser-Sicherheit ist eines der äh am meisten äh,
eines der Themen, auf der der größte Angriffsdruck hängt und da ist die Evolution zügig.
Genau, also das heißt nicht, dass ihr die anderen Sachen nicht auch updaten sollt, aber auf jeden Fall die Brausen.
Die Brausen ganz besonders updaten. Dann äh gab's ein ein lustiges Hackback.
Kundbarkeit das.
Ein lustiges Hack und Back bei äh der NRW Agrarministerin Christina Schulze-Vöcking äh die mir jetzt äh nicht.
Bekannt war.
Neben mir auch nicht.
Ähm.
Aber die gute Frau Ministerin hat ein bisschen Ärger mit Tierschützern, weil die Familie Schulze Höcking Schulze Vöcking ähm in Steinfurt einen Mastbetrieb unterhält,
Und in diesem also Schweinemast würde ich jetzt vermuten, ne? Also werden Tiere gemästet und äh das ist natürlich irgendwie ähm.
Wahrscheinlich auch aus guten Gründen einer starken Kritik ausgesetzt von unterschiedlichen,
Tierschutzorganisation unter anderem ist da die Tierschutzorganisation äh Tierretter e. V. Wohl mal äh da in den Schweinemastbetrieb,
gelangt und hat dort,
Filmmaterial angefertigt, äh wo man also die Tiere mit äh Verletzungen an Gelenken, Entzündungen und so weiter sieht, äh was eben äh klassische,
Phänomene der Massentierhaltung sind, weshalb man sowas ja auch eigentlich nicht isst. Aber hm.
Jetzt wird berichtet, die gute Frau Schulze Vöcking hat wohl abends in ihrem Wohnhaus vor ihrem Fernseher gesessen und ähm weil sie natürlich äh eine Frau von Welt ist, besitzt sie nicht einfach im Fernseher, sondern ein
Smart TV. Was anderes kriegst du wahrscheinlich heute auch nicht.
Das ist durch das Ding.
Also so Frau Christina Schulze-Höcking
Vöcking ist Smart TV Geschädigte und dieser Umstand wurde ausgenutzt äh um,
ihr dort eine Aufnahme aus einer Fragestunde im Landtag einzuspielen, in der es um die Schweinehandlung in ihrem Familienbetrieb gegangen war.
Haltung, um die Schweinehaltung.
Was habe ich gesagt?
Handlung. Ist egal.
Handeln die nicht mit den Ti.
Vielleicht auch, aber hier ging's erstmal darum, dass sie falsch gehalten und nicht falsch gehandelt wurden.
Vermutlich mal okay. Sie war wohl auch selber in diesen Filmaufnahmen ähm wie es äh eine Wikipedia etwas umgelenkt heißt zu fünfzig Prozent beteiligt, was auch immer das heißen mag. Ähm,
und äh seit diesem Fernsehbericht ist sie offiziell zumindest da auch in dem Schweinemastbetrieb auch nicht mehr unterwegs. Jetzt ist sie ja auch Agrarministerin, da hat sie sicherlich
andere Sachen zu tun. Also können wir nicht bewerten, inwiefern da diese Filmaufnahmen da
irgendeine Wahrheit gezeigt haben oder nicht, so wollen wir uns gar nicht so äußern, kennen wir gar nicht, haben wir nie gesehen, aber sie hat's jetzt auf jeden Fall gesehen, wurde jetzt sichergestellt
kam irgendwie aus dem eigenen Fernseher und ich würde sagen, das geht schon mal so unter Creepy äh durch so. Kommt jetzt nicht irgendwie total überrascht, also das weiß nicht,
geht das auch so, man wundert sich, dass es irgendwie so lange gedauert hat, bis man mal so eine Story äh kriegt, weil
TV. Also was heißt denn das halt, ne? Das heißt, dass die Büchsen häufig, nicht nur ähm
ähnlich wie ein Großteil der Mobiltelefone mit einem Android Betriebssystem irgendeiner äh Variante ausgestattet sind. Gibt auch noch andere
Fernseher, teilweise kommt da Web-OS zum Einsatz, weniger Hersteller mögen da vielleicht noch eigene äh Entwicklungen haben, aber im Wesentlichen irgendwas mit Linox.
Was jetzt erstmal nicht heißt, dass es so beliebig hackbar ist, aber da gehört ja dann noch eine ganze Menge mehr dazu. Das heißt, da ist eine Anwendung dafür geschrieben werden, diese ganze Benutzerführung, et cetera, Pipapo und vor allem wer schon mal in so einem Smartphone äh Smart TV
rumgeklickt hat. Da gibt's halt eben Apps für YouTube für Netflix, für all diesen ganzen Klimbim, das aktualisiert sich, das äh
Sachen runter, da wird irgendwie ja was Krippe exekutiert, da ist alles mögliche äh geskriptet, man will da irgendwie interaktive Erlebnisse haben, ja, Fernsehsender, äh, knallen einem irgendwelche Polls, um die äh äh Ohren oder man will zumindest irgendwie halbwegs
intelligent in Anführungsstrichen auf das Fernsehprogramm teilnehmen, äh, rückblicken oder das mit 'ner Mediathek zu verknüpfen, durchaus teilweise auch sinnvolle und wünschenswerte äh Funktionalitäten nur
natürlich kommt das Ganze mit dem Preis, wie eben beim PC, beim Print Web Broser auch
mit einer extrem angestiegenen Komplexität und da natürlich die Angriffsfläche hier relativ groß ist, also die Geräte sind
permanent im Betrieb, dauerhaft äh online und äh ist natürlich jetzt auch nicht so ist, dass das immer so gut funktioniert mit den Softwareupdates.
Genau, denn die entstehen unter einem echt massiven Preisdruck. Also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass der Fernsehmarkt einer ist, wo also weiß ich nicht, ich habe den Fernseher besessen, aber.
Viele Modelle gibt's nach dem Jahr so gar nicht mehr. Da kommen dann Update.
Äh da muss ein Neuer und jetzt muss hier aber einundachtzig Zoll und jetzt aber super HD und haste nicht gesehen und drei D und was nicht alles.
Genau und es ist auch an sich,
extrem promissgegräte, nicht, die also jetzt auch WLAN haben, die Bluetooth haben, um alle möglichen, ne, Lautsprecher et cetera zu unterstützen. Die wollen von allem irgendwie ferngesteuert werden, den sind A
da draußen, mit dem man sie fernsteuern kann, alles so Convenient, Convenience und das ist halt so das, wo die gleich große Ohren kriegen, ne? Also mit so viel äh
Varianten und Kombinationsmöglichkeiten.
Sind die Dinger einfach zu billig.
Ja und dafür sind sie einfach zu.
Dafür sind sie zu billig und unter unterliegen einem zu schnellen Druck. So, ich meine, diese, ich nehme ja gerne immer als Vergleich so ein Computer.
Ein Betriebssystem wird wie jetzt Windows XP über dreizehn Jahre, kriegt das Nachsorge von Microsoft,
irgendwie so nur so als Beispiel, was die Komplexität dieser Systeme angeht. Und dass das Commitment kannst du eben leisten,
Wenn du sagst, ich bin hier der Microsoft und ich mache jetzt hier Windows Experience, ich verkaufe das Millionen oder Milliardenfach und habe viele äh Kunden und so weiter
wenn du aber sagst, ich bin hier hoch im Flower Power Interprise und wir haben einundfünfzig Zoll Fernseher und der muss jetzt schnell in den Media Markt bevor die anderen zweiundfünfzig Zoll Fernseher gebaut haben, äh dann ist das das erste, woran du sparst.
Und dann steht das Ding im Schweinemastbetrieb und nee, der haben wahrscheinlich im Wohnzimmer stehen, ne?
Ja und vor allem man muss auch sagen, das mag sich jetzt in Zukunft ein bisschen ändern, aber ist noch nicht so lange her, die übliche Standzeit von Fernsehern liegt irgendwo so zwischen fünf und sieben Jahren.
Nur ich hätte ja gedacht, länger, ja, aber okay.
Das mag auch schon nochmal länger gewesen sein, so in den achtziger Jahren standen sicherlich die Dinger auch mal zehn Jahre rum. Mittlerweile äh hat sich da ja technologisch auch eine Menge getan. So und zunächst mal waren's ja die HD Schirme
und jetzt halt in der nächsten Stufe einerseits der Fika, als auch dieser ganze, ich probiere jetzt aber auch Netflix auf meinem Fernseher haben, äh, Trend, der halt zu größeren Ablösungsraten führt, aber trotz alledem ähm da ja nun
viele Haushalte einen Fernseher zulegen und jetzt nicht das jetzt unbedingt zu den Geräten gehört, die man wirklich jetzt hier einmal im Jahr updatet, weil dann fällt einem das nicht und die Größe und überhaupt und passend das zu meiner Schrankwand
Deswegen bleiben die Dinger halt einfach stehen und dann werden sie wahrscheinlich nach.
In einem Jahr oder zwei, irgendwann noch keine Softwareupdates mehr bekommen,
Das ist ein Problem. Ich meine, schaut euch an wie der Android-Markt das schon mit den Telefonen macht, die ja im Prinzip,
Verhältnismäßig hochpreisig sind. Also,
gibt natürlich auch da im Smartphone-Bereich mittlerweile den richtigen Billigmarkt, der hat im Prinzip genau dasselbe Problem wie die Fernseher, aber Fernseher also,
Der Premium-Fernsehmarkt ist noch kleiner als der Premium Smartphonemarkt. Es wird im Smartphone-Bereich noch sehr viel mehr Geld verdient. Äh trotz alledem sitzt da mit der Sicherheit schlecht aus im niedrigen Segment,
und das wird halt im Fernseherbereich wahrscheinlich auch im höheren Segment zu sein.
Im Jungen Fernseher allein der Begriff. Ja, ja, ja, gibt, es gibt Leute, die haben Premium-Fernseher.
Ja, wenn man viel Fernsehen, also Fernsehen, was heißt Fernsehen? Also wenn man viel Video schaut, ne? Ähm Kino, tralala, et cetera, also die neuen Bildschirme ersetzen natürlich auch so das klimagestützte Heimkino und ähm.
Diesen Zeiten leben wir ja jetzt.
B-Smart, Don't by Smart.
Wenn man könnte, also ist gar nicht so einfach. Probier das mal. Ist wirklich, also der Markt ist,
an der Stelle durch, ja? Also du hast echte Schwierigkeiten irgendwas zu finden, was nicht einfach komplett durchgesmartet ist.
Da muss man irgendwie auch so eine so eine kann man hier nicht diesen Minimalison Bewegung, diese ganzen Hipster oder sowas irgendwie da mal.
Fernseher, Meister.
Nee, so ein so ein ja, also ich finde das tatsächlich, dass man sagt, so ich hätte gerne einen Fernseher. Also man kann ja immer noch Displays kaufen. Zum Glück, das finde ich also das wäre jetzt so meine Methode.
Ja, nur so ist diese Displays für Computer sind und an sich bei der bei der vergleichbaren Bildschirmgröße äh das Drei- oder Vierfache und Mehrkosten und von daher überhaupt keine Konkurrenz hat,
Ja, also.
Warum ist das eigentlich so.
Dabei natürlich die äh Bildschirme für den Computer vielen höheren Anforderungen äh genügen müssen als die Fernseherdinger.
Ja, da kann dann auch mal ein Pixel kaputt sein et cetera und ähm die werden halt mit nicht so hoher,
Einzelqualität äh geliefert, die müssen nur irgendwie HDMI äh dran haben, et cetera und haben halt viele andere Anforderungen, die Computerbildschirme heute brauchen, nicht, gerade im Hinblick auf
Compliance mit arbeitsrechtlichen Geschichten, Abstrahlung et cetera,
Fernseher ist einfach ein Stück Elektronik, das Schraubsee, eine Schrankwand und fertig ist.
Kommt die sprechende Lampe.
Ja, also ich kann's im Einzelnen nicht genau herherleiten, was alles dazu führt, aber äh die Realität ist, du kannst nicht einfach einen Computerbildschirm kaufen in sechzig Zoll äh gibt's halt nicht vier K, so,
der nicht smart ist und nicht ein Fernseher ist, also es ist einfach existiert nicht auf dem Markt.
So
Und wenn und wenn oder und wenn er existiert, also es gibt sicher, es gibt natürlich Spezialmonitore für Sonderanwendungen im Businessbereich und so, aber das ist dann halt einfach, dass dass es dann eben der Premiumfernseher.
Premiumfernseher. Kauft euch lieber ordentliche Kopfhörer, dann klingen wir besser.
Genau, da sind die Investitionen, da kommen wir noch mit wenigen hundert Euro schon in Premium.
In dem Premiumbereich, ja? Wunderbar.
Dann noch Premium konnte dazu.
Kostenloser Premium-Content.
Ich würde sagen, wir kommen zu den Terminen.
So und so viel haben wir überhaupt gar nicht äh anzukündigen, aber,
eins auf jeden Fall, nämlich das Wireless Battlemash. Das Ganze,
ist eine Veranstaltung so aus dieser Freifunk äh Community, international angelegt, also das war alles Community äh Weekend steckt da noch mit äh drin und man trifft sich in Berlin vom siebten Mai
bis zum dreizehnten Mai,
Das zieht sich, würde ich sagen, ne. Und ist wohl äh fünfzehnter Geburtstag auch des Wildes Community Weekends und von daher groß aufgehängt. Ähm man trifft sich irgendwo.
In der Seaway ist.
In der Seabays, alles klar, wo denn sonst? Seebase in Berlin und da könnt ihr dabei nehmen und äh teilnehmen und Eintritt ist frei.
Jo und dann gibt es vom,
Am achtzehnten und neunzehnten Juni an der Ecole Politik Nick Federal Delozan ein Summer Research Institut. Meine Güte, jetzt haben wir alle Sprachen, die ich spreche zusammen.
Äh dieses Mal mit einem Fokus auf Security Privacy und Crypto, einige sehr interessante Speaker sind am Start. Mehr Details dazu unter
Dem Link in den Shownots, weil der echt nicht aussprechbar ist,
Die Veranstaltung ist kostenlos äh und offen für alle, die dorthin wollen und jetzt sei es auch empfohlen.
Ja und das äh bringt uns dann tatsächlich ans Ende. Diese Sendung hat auf jeden Fall dazu beigetragen, die durchschnittliche Sendungsdauer dieses Produkts äh nach oben zu treiben. Mal gucken, ob wir auf dein,
Wunschzeitraum schon gelandet sind.
Weiß ich nicht. Ich sehe nur gerade dieses diese Veranstaltung an der Uni Losan hat tatsächlich den ein oder anderen größeren Namen da. Ja.
Wirklich. So, so auch da.
Nee, wieder nicht.
Mensch Mensch Mensch. Irgendwie ist das man kann das so groß nicht sagen.
Nee, es stimmt. Ist nur Mad Green. Okay, dann sind wir hiermit am Ende des Geschehens angelangt,
und damit auch an der Stelle an der ich gerne danke,
Und zwar danke ich diese Woche dem Markus. Markus, ich glaube, du musst dich bei mir melden, weil du scheinst einen Komma-Fehler gemacht zu haben.
Komma Fehler Strikes Black.
Ja, so, ich würde schätzen, zwei Stellen Komma Fehler. Äh dann Joachim, Sören, Christian, Sebastian und Konstanze gebührt der Dank.
Wir auch allen anderen Ungenannten, die hier regelmäßig dazu beitragen, inhaltlich finanziell und äh von der Motivation her ähm.
Uns hier eine gute Zeit zu machen, damit wir euch eine gute Zeit bringen können und,
Ihr wisst ja, bald machen wir nochmal richtig Sause. Dazu dann später mehr. Bis dahin sagen wir tschüss, bis bald.
Ciao ciao.